The president's car is now turning onto Elm Street and it will be only a matter of minutes before he arrives at the trademark.
It appears as though something has happened in the motorcade route.
The JFK files were just released.
The National Archives released thousands of new pages of declassified records related to President John F. Kennedy's assassination.
80,000 pages of documents is a lot to sift through. Can you just tell us who killed Kennedy?
Who should be held culpable?
I don't want to point my finger at anyone in a case like this.
Numerous people running up the hill alongside Elm Street.
Who were the two men on the grassy knoll? Who were they?
This guy's like a radio man. He looks like a Cuban. He's out of place.
And he's sitting right next to the umbrella man.
There's Rip Robertson, photographs of Rip Robertson, who's the field operations commander for the S-Force.
Standing right there in Dilley Plaza, you've got Ed Lansdale.
Photographs of Lansdale sitting right there and his wife identifying him.
The thing that I find to be so special about what we now know is the relationship that Oswald,
had with all these guys.
Back up, man!
Did you shoot the president?
I'm just a patsy.
All of this is a side product of deception, duplicity.
And to think that he was alone, taken completely by surprise by this.
Nonsense. It's nonsense, man. It was all set up by the highest levels.
And they got away with it for 62 years.
Maybe you should interview me.
You know, the JFK files were just released.
Archives, a short time ago, released thousands of new pages of declassified records related to President John F. Kennedy's assassination.
You have 80,000 documents that require a lot of, you know, artificial intelligence overlay,
optical character recognition to make any sense of.
Even then, I think very few people made any sense of them.
I think they left more confused.
There's a great quote by Brett Weinstein where it's like looking through the JFK files is like looking for a needle in the haystack where the needle is missing.
And even President Trump, when he was asked,
point blank, who killed JFK after the file drop, he said, we released the files.
We did a historic thing or whatever.
80,000 pages of documents is a lot to sit through.
Can you just tell us who killed Kennedy?
Well, you know, I was given the task of releasing that because many presidents have gone through it and they haven't released.
And I said, release. We even released Social Security numbers.
I didn't want anything deleted.
They said, sir, what about Social Security?
The other side steps, the point blank question is who should be held culpable?
And I don't think anybody has a good answer to that after that file release.
I'm here with Jeremy Riss, alien scientist.
You've been making epic videos for 20 years on not only UFOs and aliens, but often the science,
the secret science behind all this stuff, along with sprinkling some of your favorite conspiracies.
And it's, I can't wait to speak to you, man.
some phone conversations we don't agree on everything no i don't have to we don't have
to that's the point of having conversations and uh i'm excited to have you man thank you for being
here for sure man thanks for having me it's great to finally be here absolutely all right well
there's so many jumping off points there were just these jfk disclosures right like what eighty
thousand how many documents like a whole bunch and then there's you know how many how many things
that didn't write down you know you think like you're planning to murder somebody you don't
write stuff down and keep a blog and a whole bunch of incriminating evidence on yourself so
there's a lot of cool stuff in the documents that have come out so far but you know really
you learn more uh from talking to long-term assassination researchers who've been way more
i feel like people come out came out of this way more confused than a lot of people did yeah
there's a lot of the the media use it as an opportunity to once again you know hype up this
uh idea that oh there's nothing in the documents there's nothing new
here and there's nothing new here and there's nothing new here and there's nothing new here
here. This is all just conspiracy theories. You know, the typical Operation Mockingbird mantras
and whatnot. But yeah, really, the JFK research community has cracked this case and they've
cracked it for a number of years. I mean, Jim Mars was one of the first with Crossfire. That
was the book that Oliver Stone's JFK was based on. And that really laid the foundation for a lot of
the investigations that followed. And there's been decades and decades and tons of people have dug
into this from every possible angle. And now it's just come out that, you know, Priscilla
McMillan, who interviewed Lee when he went to Russia and also befriended Marina Oswald and
wrote her autobiography for her. She's a CIA agent. She's a witting CIA asset. And that came
out in one of the things that was revealed in the documents, which shows the level that they went
through to get ahead of the sources and the story and be like, all right, we're going to,
we're going to, we're going to, we're going to, we're going to, we're going to, we're going to,
we're going to put our people in so that anyone getting information about this from the sources
has to go through us basically. So I know you to be, uh, you know, as deep on the topic as
maybe anybody alive and you have a very coherent narrative. So what do you think happened? Who,
who killed JFK? They actually, the shot that was fired from the knoll that killed him was, uh,
was Morales, uh, David Morales. And, and he was called the Mexican. They're kind of different
nicknames. They had,
they were, but he was the crack shot, uh, out of the team, the S force team that had been put
together to kill Fidel Castro. And it was a triangular, uh, a fire team, uh, plan, you know,
to have three gunmen crossfire at a moving target. That was the plan. That was the structure that
they'd set up and that they trained down in Oaxaca, Mexico, you know, uh, at the ranch of,
uh, of Clint Murchison jr. And they trained them up down there to do that, to kill not, not only
Fidel Castro, but Raul Castro and Che Guevara and five other commandantes they had on the list.
Hmm. So this was the 5412 committee, which was run by Nixon under Eisenhower. He's setting up
these sort of covert operations to take out Che Guevara and Castro, but then they get used in
the assassination of JFK. How, how does that occur? Well, well, what happened, what happened
is the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the, the people on the task force, the people that were recruited to be on the, the S force to
kill Castro, uh, in short Castro and Che Guevara and the others that they were rabid anti-communist,
uh, Cubanos that had fled from Cuba in January of 1959 when Batista was overthrown and they all
fled up to Florida and camped out basically in Miami and Tampa, uh, primarily.
And the, a lot of them were mafia gunmen that worked for Santos traffic Conti, who was the Don
of the mafia, uh, in Havana and ran the gambling casinos, the houses of prostitution, but most
importantly, the heroin smuggling that was coming in from Southeast Asia, because that was critical
because the portion of the profits from the heroin sales that were going on through the mafia run by
Santos traffic Conti and the Gambinos that they were running.
The, the heroin into the United States and a portion of the profits that were being skimmed off
that sale were being used to purchase military equipment and explosives to, to smuggle to the
Kuomintang in China.
Whoa.
So this is pre Iran Contra, but the same sort of architecture.
Oh yeah.
Same, same move.
And, and, and that they were in, that's where they got the idea to keep doing it, you know, so that
they, they had the whole thing set up for the, the portion of the heroin income was being used to
purchase the explosives and weapons.
There was a company set up, uh, with offices in Havana and in Miami that was the sea supply
corporation, they called it.
And on the face of it is the S E a O it's a sea supply corporation, some kind of maritime thing.
It was a Southeast Asian supply company run by Paul Halliwell, the full-time central intelligence
agency employee running the operation.
Uh, he was getting the money to the Kuomintang.
He was getting, he was actually using the money from the heroin smuggling, a portion of it to purchase
the weapons and explosives here.
And then they would fly them from here.
And that was that whole Terry and the pirates thing, what they call flying the hump that they, they had
this whole operation that a fellow named William D.
Pauli, uh, was, it worked for Prentice, uh, aviation and they were providing the airplanes and they were
smuggling them and flying them into China.
Uh, so there was a, and you know, her, uh, Claire Booth Luce was involved in it.
Uh, Henry Luce's wife.
That's right.
And it was in Dulles was involved.
They were all involved in it.
That's what they call the China lobby.
That was that whole group that right from way back had figured that they were planning to really turn the, the
development operations of their economic investments into Asia.
And, and Henry Luce then starts life and time magazine, which publishes the Zapruder film with the missing
frames of the JFK assassination.
That's right.
So that's a very interesting connection as well.
Which is, as you know, I mean, I know the guy that got the film, Dick Billings, Dick Billings and knew all about
how they, they brought it to Rochester and doctored it.
He, he sat and told me about the whole thing.
That's wild.
So he talks about them doctoring the film and, and taking certain frames out and stuff.
And did the frames involve David Morales and the other, no, it just, it, it, it, uh, it made it clear that he was
being, he was shot from the front.
Okay.
You could tell.
You could tell from that thing so that they reversed the actual, uh, frames of the, of the film.
And then the, the guy who let out the Zapruder film is a guy named Charles Douglas Jackson, who was, uh, basically
ran psychological warfare for the United States.
He was, uh, in the psychological strategy board with Gordon Gray and some of these other guys.
And, um, he let out the Zapruder film in life magazine, which he was involved with, but with missing frames.
And so.
And that was a big thing.
The other guy that ran the psychological warfare program.
For JM wave, a station was George Joannidis.
And it recently came out that, you know, these files prove that he lied about his involvement with the program.
Cause they asked him who ran the program.
He said, I don't know.
I'll have to look and check for you.
And he never got back.
They never got back to that question.
Never resolved that.
Well, he's the one that ran the program.
How do you not know who ran the program?
You ran the program and you lied about it to Congress and in front of it and the whole entire of America.
So that one, that one came out.
That was it.
That was a huge one and slinger too.
That, uh, not.
And slinger, um, Angleton, James, Jesus, Angleton, and, uh, he was running this whole, um, spying program and the male intercept program.
And this guy, Reuben Efron was in charge of that.
And, um, Reuben Efron is in the, in the files and they ask him about, do you know Reuben Efron?
And he says, no, that's a lie.
You hired Reuben Efron and he ran the spy program for you.
That was reading Lee Harvey Oswald's mail and spying on this dude for years.
Cause he had a two Oh one file into the CIA since 1959.
So that they were, they have a massive file on Lee Harvey Oswald, following all his actions and to think that he was alone, not that we didn't know, we had no idea.
And we were taken completely by surprise by this nonsense.
It's nonsense, man.
It was all set up by the highest levels and they got away with it for 60, 62 years.
But it's, it's, I don't want it to be too confusing to everybody.
It's, it's easier kind of having in a chronological structure to understand how this thing happened, because it's a, that the entire.
Operation was set up way back in 1960.
You know, when, uh, when, uh, when, when Fidel Castro in Che Guevara and the guys overthrew Batista and drove them out in January of 1959, Richard Nixon as the vice president under Eisenhower and the chair of the 5412 committee, the supervised covert operations.
He sent all kinds of communications to Fidel Castro saying, look, you are fine.
You've overthrown Batista.
Okay.
It's a deal.
What we want to do is make sure you don't have any diplomatic relations with China or Russia.
You can't have, and he said, you can't have any kind of relations with them at all.
And Fidel Castro said, screw you.
Who do you think you're talking to here?
You know, uh, and you know, they, they, you know, wave the old Monroe doctrine flag at him and so, which he didn't give a crap about, you know, and, and so Nixon got really PO with him.
And so he then set up this covert operation, which was called originally operation 40.
Okay.
And then he recruited naturally enough, he recruited a whole bunch of, uh, a whole bunch of Batista supporters, uh, who supported the fascist authoritarian regime down there, uh, and worked directly with Santos Traficante because Santos Traficante was the business partner of Batista and Paul Helliwell in running the heroin operations.
And it was just a means of covert funding for the operations to oppose China, to oppose Mao Tse Tung.
Mm-hmm.
This is amazing.
Yeah.
And, and they didn't, they didn't want to tell Congress about it at all because they didn't think they could muster enough support from Congress to actually support covert operations against Mao Tse Tung.
So they did it totally covertly.
They, the CIA sent up this entire operation, uh, to be supporting, uh, Chiang Kai-shek, uh, in the so-called nationalist forces and the chief of security for, for, uh, Chiang Kai-shek was the head of the green gang, the major heroin operation in, in China.
No.
No way.
Oh, yeah.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That is wild.
Okay.
So in 59, 60 timeframe, you have the 54, 12 commission and committee rather you have, of which Nixon is ahead and he's sort of, you know, running kind of national security.
He, uh, partners with, uh, mafia dons like Traficante.
Well, actually, actually he avoided that one by one step.
What he did is recruited Howard Hughes.
Howard Hughes.
Yeah.
He called Howard Hughes because Howard Hughes was a consultant to the 54, 12 committee.
Uh, he would, he had designed the Spruce goose, which became the prototype for the C5A cargo plane that could fly, you know, major covert operations in and equipment and stuff.
Uh, and he also, he also designed the Goldmar Explorer, uh, that ship that could pick up Russian submarines off the bottom of the ocean and stuff that they felt through and a couple other extraordinarily sensitive programs that he was working on.
He was working on.
Like what?
Yeah.
I can't tell you.
I can't tell you that.
Uh, because of the way I know.
You've said this before to me about Howard Hughes.
And then I always go, is it the UFO stuff?
You go, no.
No, no, it wasn't that.
It was.
What else could be so sensitive?
Is it like time travel or something?
No, no, no, no.
Nothing esoteric like that.
You're a man of the people, Danny.
We need to know.
Yeah.
As evidenced by Tim Dillon's recent and masterful interview with CNN, legacy media can be a bit problematic.
It's more sensationalist and divided than ever.
They ask leading questions brainwashed by their social mill use, and that's why people are flocking to podcasts, but podcasts have their own limits.
They're often three hours long.
They're not super efficient.
They aren't always fact checked.
There's sort of a hybrid of entertainment and news.
So how do I stay informed amidst this backdrop?
I started using my new favorite service ground news, a tool designed for both skeptics and truth seekers.
Like many.
Yeah.
Like I said, ground news is an app and website created by a former NASA engineer to tackle a problem we all face.
How distorted the information is that we consume every day in the modern post truth era.
Ground news gathers coverage from over 50,000 sources worldwide, organizes the stories by topic and even breaks down the bias and ownership behind each perspective.
So you know what you're getting with features like the bias bar and factuality score.
It's easy to see how different outlets frame and spin the same.
story when you eat certain foods you want to see the ingredients list this is the same thing but
for content and news for example when i was researching those mysterious drone sightings
in new jersey in december ground news gave me instant access to over 200 articles helping me
uncover every angle from the facts to the spin spoiler alert i don't think they were just faa
approved research drones so if you're tired of echo chambers and one-sided narratives ground
news is your ultimate tool for staying informed and making better decisions you can follow your
favorite topics and compare coverage to find the most credible sources and for a limited time you
can get the same plan i use every day for nearly half the price just go to ground.news jesse
michaels michaels with no a or scan this qr code to save 40 on their unlimited access vantage plan
or gift it to someone you know and have more informed discussions and hopefully chill out
about those drones i only promote youtube content so if you're interested please check out youtube
brands I vet and I think you'll find them just as valuable as I do ground
news the truth is out there you just need the right tools to find it it's it's
one of those it's one of those kind of things that one of the very rare things
that I I tend to agree that it would be good to tell people about it sure you
know it would generate all kinds of damage and it wouldn't really benefit
anybody got it it was the bottom line is but because of that he trusted Hughes
and so he contacts him using the the the red phone this the secure phone which he
had from 54 12 committee communications called Howard Hughes and in traffic
auntie told us all this this all came directly from traffic auntie about how
the whole thing happened and actually told us the the the day on which Richard
Nixon called on Howard Hughes and told him that he was going to be able to get
back on the phone Howard Hughes was the day after uh Nelson Rockefeller withdrew
from the 1960 Republican presidential primary race against Nixon uh because as
soon as he withdrew Nixon knew he was going to be the nominee for the Republican
party in 1960 and he was sure he was going to win right so he then he then took upon
himself the authority basically of the incoming president to contact Hughes and ask him
to put together an assassination team what's the why did Rockefeller step down right then I don't
quite he just withdrew he he withdrew from the primary race for the was that a coincidence or
no no is but what it did is it it it freed up uh Nixon uh-huh to realize he was going to be
the nominee for the Republican Party and so he was therefore confident he was getting ready to
be president yeah so he started exercising the kind of a power that a president might
do and so he took on to himself this kind of Authority to actually reach out
and have Howard Hughes set up an assassination team.
He said, but you've got to keep it
completely away from the White House.
So you can't, you've just got to do it yourself.
And so what Howard Hughes did
is sent for one of his lawyers that he had, Bob Mayhew.
And had Mayhew, he assigned Mayhew,
he said, here's the job.
The president kept,
they started referring to him as the president
in their communication.
Traffic County said so.
Oh my God.
They kept referring to him as the president.
To Nixon as the president.
Yeah, they kept referring to him as the president.
Didn't know he was the VP.
No, yeah.
And it said, you know, that he wants this done.
He wants to keep it away from the White House.
And so, so Bob Mayhew went to see,
because, you know, Howard Hughes was in Las Vegas
and he was hanging out at the,
I can't remember if it was the,
whether it was the Flamingo or the Sands,
one of the two.
But anyway, he was up in the big penthouse there
and it was one of the mob hotels, right?
And so he knew that they were there.
And so Bob Mayhew went to see Johnny Roselli,
who was the bag man, you know,
for the mafia skim.
The skimming the cash off those casinos to be used, right?
And so his principal, the guy in charge of him
was Sam Giancana out of Chicago.
And so when Bob Mayhew went to Johnny Roselli and said,
look, you guys have your own reason
for wanting to get rid of this Castro dude.
You know, he shut down all your casinos,
shut down your whore houses, he said.
And very importantly,
they've cut off the whole heroin supply, okay?
And so that you got your own reasons
for wanting to get rid of him.
So, you know,
that Nixon is assuming that you'll do this for us.
And so Johnny Roselli said, well, you know,
I don't have the authority to make a decision like that.
We're going to have to talk to Sam Giancana.
And so they went together, you know,
Johnny Roselli and Bob Mayhew went to Chicago
and met with Sam Giancana
and pitched the proposal to him.
And Sam Giancana realized that, you know,
doing a favor like this for the president
was going to get them a lot of potential,
goodwill, right?
And so, and keep them,
keep the feds off their back.
So he was agreeing in principle to do it.
He said, but, you know, but this isn't up to me.
That's Santos Traficante's territory.
That's down in Havana.
He's the mob boss in Havana.
He's, even though he's up in Tampa now,
because he left Cuba,
he said, so we have to go talk to him.
So they went down.
They went down to see him.
Now they were down there about September or so.
This all started around June, around June 7th.
That was when Rockefeller withdrew.
June 7th of 1960.
So between that, it was now early September.
Johnny Roselli, Bob Mayhew, and Sam Giancana
went down to Florida
and at the Fontainebleau Hotel
met with Traficante.
And they had two meetings
in which finally Traficante tells us
that he said, you know,
I agreed in principle.
I agreed in principle to do this.
He said, but I wanted to make sure that,
you know, he said, it wasn't some kind of brain fart,
he said, you know, on the part of Bob Mayhew
or even Howard Hughes.
Wanted to make certain
that this was coming from the president.
That's how he termed it.
He said, and so that they had a third meeting
and a guy, another guy comes to the meeting
at the Fontainebleau Hotel
using the nom de guerre, Mr. Ed.
And it was Sheffield Edwards, who was there.
He was the chief of security
of the Central Intelligence Agency under Dulles, okay?
And under the Eisenhower-Bush administration.
But so he comes to the meeting
and gives them the green light to go ahead and do this.
And so that's, so what Traficante did
is he recruited guys from his people
that were from Havana,
these gunmen that he had down there
that were enforcers who had, that were, you know,
that were enforcers who had, you know,
fled with him to Florida in January of 59
and had gotten recruited by Richard Nixon and the CIA
to run covert operations against Cuba.
Because when Fidel Castro just finally thumbed his nose at,
at Nixon and said, you know, screw you,
I'm gonna have relations with anybody I want.
So I'll have diplomatic relations with Russia and China,
you know, therefore, quote, violating the Monroe Doctrine,
you know, of allowing a foreign power
to start having influence inside our hemisphere,
you know, or our zone of influence.
And so, so what happened is Richard Nixon
had mounted this covert operation
and he'd recruited all of these people
that were Traficante gunmen and mobsters basically,
but virulent anti-communists, you know,
and were all in around Miami.
They had the 2506 Brigade, they had Alpha 66.
There were a bunch of these kind of,
it's unfair to call them covens,
but I mean, they were, they were these,
these gangs like that were there
that were engaged in covert operation.
And so they thought that they were kind of invested
with kind of a certain kind of authority
on the part of the federal government,
because they're paid by the CIA to do this.
And they set up these, these bases.
They set one up on No Name Key.
They set one up on Swan Island.
They put one in the Everglades.
And then they had two of them at Lake Palm.
They set up another train over in Louisiana,
one on the southern coast of the, of Lake Palm's train,
one on the northern coast.
And they set up these, these paramilitary bases
in these rabidly anti-communist, pro-Baptista,
you know, Traficante gunmen, a lot of them,
you know, were covert operators
working under the auspices of the CIA
to run these covert operations.
So Traficante says, okay, Nixon wants me
to put together this assassination team.
I'm going to take my people.
Mm-hmm.
Who are working with the CIA.
But in a completely different capacity,
just to run covert operations.
Mm-hmm.
What I'm going to do is recruit 15 of them.
I'll hand-pick them, and we'll put them
into this special S-Force, they call it.
And that's what they did.
And they would send private planes to go pick them up,
you know, at these five different paramilitary bases.
They would pick up a couple of the guys at each one,
and they would fly them to Fort Huachuca in Arizona.
Mm-hmm.
And they would take electronic surveillance operations
that they've got going there in Fort Huachuca.
Mm-hmm.
And so they'd bring them there,
and then they would sign in,
and then they would just disappear off the records.
And then they were flown down to Oaxaca, Mexico,
to the ranch of Clint Murchison, Jr.,
very wealthy scion of this oil fortune down there,
who his father, his father owned the Dallas Texans.
Whoa.
Football team, you know.
Cowboys.
Yeah.
Well, later Cowboys.
It was Texans at the time.
Oh, Texans at the time.
Okay.
Interesting.
Yeah.
And that's who they were.
And, you know, horse racing and rich people and stuff.
And so they had this big ranch down in Oaxaca.
So they set up a triangular fire team base down there
to practice shooting a moving target from three different locations
to get a triangular crossfire onto the site, onto the target.
And they were training them.
And Carl Jenkins was brought in from the CIA.
To train them on this under ZR rifle.
It was the code name for the program.
But this was a whole separate thing.
And it was not even known to many people at all that this was going on
because they were trying to keep it away from the White House.
So that operation is going on.
And the way they funded it was from the skim of money off the casinos.
And they would skim the money off the casinos.
They would put the cash into these brand new big expensive suitcases.
And put them in the trunk of brand new Cadillac automobiles.
And they would drive them.
And I know the guy that sold them, the Cadillacs.
Because he had the big dealership there.
Whoa.
In Vegas.
Anyway, I interviewed him at length about it.
And so they drive the cars through New Orleans.
And Marcelo was there.
And they did the audit on all the money to keep track of how much money they were moving.
And then they would repack it.
And they would drive them into Florida.
And deposit it in the Miami National Bank of Meyer Lansky.
And then they would wire a portion of the money down into the Banco Internacional.
Down in Mexico City.
And they put it into this account by this lawyer by the name of Ogarrio.
Had the account down in the bank.
And then they would pay the cost for the whole triangular fire team training base down in Oaxaca.
And that's the.
So how do you go from this systematic drug running covert operation that ultimately is in support of the resistance in China.
The Guomingtang and the Chiang Kai-shek.
How do you go from that and then this plan initially to take out Che Guevara and Castro.
Who are impinging upon the Monroe Doctrine.
Yes.
To killing JFK.
Setting President.
Well.
That's the whole operation was going when suddenly Richard Nixon didn't get elected.
John F. Kennedy of the state of Massachusetts has received for President of the United States 303 votes.
Richard M. Nixon of the state of California has received 219 votes.
This is the first time in 100 years that a candidate for the presidency announced the result of an election in which he was defeated.
And announced the victory of his opponent.
All of you work in a cause that is bigger than any man's ambition.
Greater than any party.
It is the cause of freedom, of justice, and peace for all mankind.
And it is in that spirit that I now declare that John F. Kennedy has been elected President of the United States and Lyndon Johnson Vice President of the United States.
And Kennedy comes in.
And they brief Kennedy now about the Bay of Pigs plan that they had going.
But they didn't tell him about the assassination team.
At all.
Hey, guys.
I want to tell you about my new favorite piece of apparel.
These are called the perfect jeans.
They're literally the perfect jeans.
I used to wear jeans all the time.
And they're kind of rough and not super stretchy or breathable.
These are extremely comfortable.
They work in casual environments.
They work in work settings.
They come in six different sizes from 26 inches to 50 inches.
And they're all around just amazing.
For a limited time, our listeners get 15% off your first order.
Plus, free shipping at theperfectjean.nyc.
Again, that's theperfectjean.nyc.
Or just Google the perfect jean.
Use code JESSE15 for that 15% off.
Again, that's code JESSE15.
That's 15% off for new customers at theperfectjean.nyc.
After purchase, they'll ask where you heard about them.
Please support our show and tell them that we sent you.
Fuck your khakis.
Get the perfect jean.
And so they lure him into allowing the invasion to go on,
the attempted invasion at the Bay of Pigs.
But he tells them right from the very beginning that he won't provide air cover.
He won't provide any air cover.
And he won't provide any kind of U.S. military intervention.
You know, they wanted to be able to land on the beach
and basically raise the flag of freedom.
They wanted to free Cuba and then ask for U.S. intervention
and do it the old-fashioned way.
You know, just send in a paramilitary operation.
And Kennedy wouldn't do it.
And they said, oh, he said, look, if you're telling me
that the people of Cuba want to rise up against Castro
because they're so unhappy with him,
if they land on the beach and they raise the flag of a free Cuba,
if the people all rally and toss out Castro, good.
If you're telling me the truth that they're going to do it,
you go ahead and do it.
And what happened is they had two or three B-25s,
these old bomber planes that were down in Nicaragua, actually,
that the Somoza, Anastasio Somoza, was supporting them in doing this.
You know, it was this kind of right-wing fascist dude.
And so the bottom line is that they were going to provide their own air cover for this.
And what happened is they were in a different time zone.
And so they got there an hour late after the landing.
And the guys had been knifed, whacked already.
They sank their ammunition boat and everything, you know.
And so they were trapped on the beach and they all got arrested.
And the whole thing fell through.
Wednesday, April 19th, resistance ends.
All those who are not killed are taken prisoner.
And then Kennedy took responsibility for it.
And this is where the thing starts.
Kennedy took responsibility for it.
And the Cubano guys that got all arrested were upset at him
for refusing not only to provide air support, but they had, you know,
that in fact General Curtis LeMay and other folks from the Joint Chiefs
had actually moved U.S. military forces into place.
They put naval ships with Marines in them, you know,
staged them contrary to the orders of the president, you know,
ordered in Marines.
There was so much at the time that Curtis LeMay felt the liberty to do by himself.
Like he put apparently, I didn't even know this,
during the Cuban Missile Crisis later, obviously,
he put us into DEFCON 2 without the president's permission.
He did.
It's crazy.
And launched the U-2, ordered the U-2 to fly over Russia to do the final retargeting,
which was, and did it at a low altitude that he knew the Russians would pick it up
to send them the signals.
He was trying to goad them.
Yeah.
He was trying to goad them into trying to initiate a nuclear war, you know.
So the bottom line is that all that was going on at this time,
and what happened is Kennedy took responsibility for it,
of the snafu.
And what he did is he apologized to Khrushchev
for having allowed that thing to go down
and gave him, gave Khrushchev, Kennedy did, his solemn promise
that he would cease and desist from efforts to undermine the government in Cuba.
And he went down to Cuba, went down to Miami at the Orange Bowl, actually,
and convened, you know, a whole meeting of all these kind of right-wing Cubano refugees
that had fled from there.
And the whole stadium, he apologized to them all in person
and said that he gave them his personal guarantee
that the free flag of Cuba would be flying over the island by the end of his second term.
And he said that to them.
I can assure you that this flag will be returned
to this brigade in a free Havana.
They said, okay, we got you.
And he turned around and had lied to Khrushchev
and actually converted Operation 40 into Operation Mongoose.
That's all it did.
It set up the big operation on the University of Miami campus called JM Wave,
this great big gigantic airplane set of hangars,
and they had all the operations going on there.
It was a full-scale war operation going on against Cuba.
And so he continued doing that.
And so Khrushchev said, screw you then,
and started moving missiles in.
And so all this was happening all right in that first period from 1961.
He's elected in November of 1960,
comes into office in January of 1961.
You know, he does all this apologizing and stuff
because it was in April of 61
that the Bay of Pigs thing came down.
And so he apologizes, but he's totally pissed off,
you know, at the CIA for bungling this whole operation.
And the days of Allen Dulles were numbered.
And so he waited all the way till the fall,
September, October, you know, of 61,
and then pushed Dulles out.
But Dulles didn't leave.
He didn't leave Washington.
He had his whole setup over there.
He had his whole setup over in Georgetown
in his big brownstone over there.
And all of the guys from the CIA
were going over to meet with him like every day.
He had like a social club.
Wasn't it called the Georgetown Set?
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Yeah.
Georgetown's a very, we won't get too far,
but it's a very interesting place, you know,
with every administration.
You've got these very wealthy, social people.
Beautiful, brownstone, kind of old houses.
I've been in a bunch of them.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And again recently, the new administration
has got people over there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember being in Michael Pillsbury's house,
which I think was JFK's old house.
Yeah.
In Georgetown.
And just being like, this is amazing.
Yeah.
So cool.
I mean, he's been a kind of lead China expert
in every administration since Nixon.
Yeah.
It's a very elite group over there.
Mm-hmm.
So the bottom line is that, you know,
so the whole operation shifts over to Operation Mongoose,
being run out of JM Wave,
and crew chefs are sending the missiles in to Cuba,
and then they discover the missiles in there.
The whole Cuban Missile Crisis comes down, right?
Within the past week,
unmistakable evidence has established the fact
that a series of offensive missile sites
is now in preparation on that imprisoned island.
Goes all the way through into late October, right?
And then this bizarre thing happens with the UFO, right?
That...
And we'll just set that aside for a moment.
Yeah.
Because it's a very kind of
comparable new piece of information.
Mm-hmm.
But the bottom line is that by the time
they get to October 26th, the night of October 26th,
they come to within like two minutes.
Mm-hmm.
This whole thing with...
with General Curtis LeMay
trying to instigate an actual nuclear exchange...
Mm-hmm.
...with Russia, saying that,
look, the most...
the Russia, if they launch nuclear missiles against us,
the most... they'll kill maybe 40 million people.
Mm-hmm.
You know, but we'll wipe them all out,
and we'll get rid of that entire scourge of communism
coming out of Russia, and then we'll win.
Mm-hmm.
Because we've only lost 40 million people,
and we'll have eliminated Russia as a threat.
And that was his whole thinking, right?
Yeah.
And the bottom line is Kennedy is so completely horrified...
...at how close they came to the nuclear war.
This is where it starts now.
Mm-hmm.
And what happened is he reached back out to Khrushchev...
...said, okay, you're right, I lied to you.
You know, we... you're right,
we kept on doing the Operation Mongoose, you know,
but you shouldn't have put the missiles in there.
We're gonna make a deal, you know,
that I'll take the missiles out of Turkey,
you take the missiles out of here,
you take the missiles out of here.
And he ordered all of those bases,
those paramilitary bases,
to cease and desist from any further operations.
But he didn't know about the assassination team...
Mm-hmm.
...that had been deployed.
But he ordered this shutting down of all the bases.
And what happens is in December,
December of 1962...
Mm-hmm.
...Frank Sturgis, who is the CIA liaison...
...to the Cubano guys out on No Name Key...
Mm-hmm.
...he decides he's gonna,
even after getting the orders from the president...
Mm-hmm.
...that they're all to stand down
and to discontinue their operations,
he, in complete defiance with the Cubans,
launches an assault into Cuba and sinks a Russian ship.
Whoa.
Which, like, nobody knows about, you know, anymore.
But they sank a Russian ship...
When was this?
It was December of 1962.
Whoa.
Sinks a Russian ship.
Kennedy freaks out...
Yeah.
...over the fact that, you know,
he'd already lied to Khrushchev once,
and he couldn't stand for doing it again.
You know, the whole thing would fall apart.
And so what he does is he sends in,
he and Bobby, who's the attorney general,
they send in six helicopter crews.
They send in six helicopter gunships with U.S. Marshals,
because he couldn't trust the FBI because of Hoover.
And so he sends in U.S. Marshals,
and they burn out the base at No Name Keep
and arrest all those guys, including Sturgis...
Wow.
...and charge them with a violation of the Neutrality Act,
mounting military operations against a country
with whom we have diplomatic relations.
Right.
And hold them for almost a week and then let them go.
Mm-hmm.
Okay?
But it's kind of a shot across the bow.
Yeah.
The president's serious.
They jeez in on it.
You know, you're not going to do this anymore.
Mm-hmm.
Then a second group, the ones in the Everglades...
...under the liaison of E. Howard Hunt...
Mm-hmm.
...start planning another attack into Cuba...
...in complete defiance of the president,
even after what they had done over on No Name Keep.
And so Bobby and John send in the same six helicopter gunships
and burn them out, too.
Mm-hmm.
And arrest them and charge them with the Neutrality Act violations.
And the heads of the 2506 Brigade and Alpha 66 resolve,
they're going to kill these guys.
They're going to kill John and Bobby,
who are complete traitors, that they've lied to them.
He came down and promised they were going to support them
in overthrowing the government.
Now they're chickening out and they want to kill him.
But they know that they can't get away with it.
You know, but they've got the S-Force that's capable
of doing something like that.
So they're all kind of, you know, just pawing away
like a charging bull wanting to get at the president
and kill him and the attorney general both, you know.
But they can't get away with this.
And so what happens is Kennedy, turns out, starts secretly...
This is the key to this thing.
He starts secretly exchanging letters with Khrushchev
through Norman Cousins.
This guy is running 18 different letters back and forth,
completely off-channel.
No State Department oversight, no CIA coverage, anything.
Completely secret communications.
And in those letters, they're deciding...
They're both so totally traumatized by what happened
and how their military forces can get out of control.
And the nuclear weapons that threat the total annihilation
of our whole human species.
So they can't let this happen.
So what they do is they start discussing
how they're going to order...
Each of them is going to exercise
their respective executive authority
to start ordering the disassembly of the nuclear warheads
in their respective arsenals and destroy them.
Not just take them and put them on a shelf somewhere
where they can just screw them back on in another week or so.
You know, but destroy them.
And they reach this agreement in principle.
JFK was really going for it.
He was trying to denuclearize entirely.
Totally going for it.
And there's this book, I think, called Mary's Mosaic.
Oh, yeah. Mary Pynchon.
Yeah, Mary Pynchon, who was the wife of Cord Meyer.
Cord Meyer.
Cord Meyer, you know, World War II veteran
who I believe came back with, I think, an eye patch.
And, you know, he turned him into a pacifist
and then he sort of got in with the Dulles,
Alan Dulles kind of intel cabal
and became this kind of warmonger
who I think later on,
I think later was in charge of Operation Mockingbird.
So like incepting journalism world with intel assets.
Yeah.
But also became this kind of bloodthirsty guy.
And so his wife, Mary.
Mary Pynchon Meyer was murdered.
She was an artist
and she was kind of a little more kind of spiritual hippy dippy.
LSD stuff.
So, yeah, so she had an affair with JFK.
Even more than that.
I mean, it was a prolonged.
Ongoing.
Relationship.
She became in a certain sense, his actual sort of mistress.
And they did LSD together.
Yes.
And I don't know.
Provided by Tim Leary.
That's wild.
Provided by Timothy Leary.
That's crazy.
He actually provided it to him.
I know the guy that knows him.
Of course he did.
Did it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Are you still lugging around one of those bulky worn out wallets?
You know, I am.
Your posture is not great due to that wallet.
Yeah.
Are you aware of that?
I'm currently now more self-aware of my posture.
It might be time for an upgrade.
Oh, what do you suggest?
My personal suggestion is Ridge Wallet.
Look at this sleek design.
Do you see it?
Oh, wow.
So sleek.
Yeah.
Pretty sleek.
Uh huh.
This thing holds up to 12 cards plus cash.
All in a slim, durable and stylish package too.
You took the words right out of my mouth.
Ridge Wallets feature RFID blocking technology.
So digital pickpockets won't stand a chance.
Plus with their AirTag attachment, you'll never lose your wallet again.
Where'd it go?
I lost my wallet.
I was just checking my AirTag.
Easy.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
I was recently in the Colorado mountains and if I had lost my Ridge Wallet, I would have
no problem tracking it down.
Even in the Rockies.
Right now, Ridge is having their once a year anniversary sale.
So get up to 40% off at ridge.com slash cosmic.
Just head to ridge.com slash cosmic to see their biggest sale of the year.
After you purchase, they will ask about where you heard about them.
Where did they hear about Ridge Wallet, Chris?
They heard it here first on American Alchemy.
Yeah.
Please support our show and tell them our show sent you.
Upgrade your wallet.
Thank me later.
And then I think they do LSD together, JFK and Mary Meyer.
And this is sort of rumor mill stuff, so I'm curious to get your take.
After that, JFK, because she has this mission of like, I need to like stop these guys.
Like her husband, Gordon Meyer and all of his associates are going to like blow up the
world.
Yeah.
And she is like, we need to reign these guys in.
And she does LSD with JFK and then JFK kind of, he was already more pacifist than them,
but he becomes more pacifist.
He becomes more hardcore, like we really need to kind of denuclearize.
He saw the light, you know, and he went through this metanoia, as we refer to it, this metanoia
experience about how incredible this was, you know, and how extraordinarily outrageous,
you know, Curtis LeMay and the Joint Chiefs have been, you know, and they'd already proposed
to him this Operation Northwoods, you know, oh, okay, because they were so desperate wanting
to get Castro out of there.
And they were so dedicated in their mission to preserve US complete domination and control
of the whole Western hemisphere that they viewed this as an absolute horrible affront
to have these guys in Cuba.
So they were just desperate to get the island overthrown.
So they kept trying everything to do it.
So the bottom line is when Kennedy is exchanging these letters and very important thing that
people don't know about is that, that Khrushchev recommended that in order to verify that they
were both complying with the actual, not only the disassembly, but the destruction of the
nuclear warheads is that they were going to have Pope John 23rd broker the whole deal
and oversee the whole process.
No way.
That's all true.
Are you serious?
That's absolutely right.
Khrushchev wrote about this in his letters back?
They were, yes, they did it in the letters.
And these letters...
Have you seen these letters?
No, but I know what the content of them are.
How do you know?
From Jesuit headquarters.
From Jesuit headquarters because of John Paul 23rd or John 23rd was going to be the
broker.
But he dies.
I need to get in with the Jesuits, Danny, I don't know.
Yeah, right, right.
But he dies.
Yeah.
He dies in early June.
So they were working on trying to get this done.
So he dies in early June and what Kennedy decides is that in order to make up for the
massive disfunding of the whole nuclear weapons programs in both countries.
In order to have a massive economic stimulus to replace that, he wants to, and he proposes
to Gorbachev, or to Khrushchev, that they have a joint Soviet-U.S. space program.
That they completely combine their forces and they overcome the whole threat of the
Cold War and that they join forces in going into outer space together.
And he, on June 5th of 1962, or 63 rather now.
Of 1963, what he does is he contacts McCone, the new CIA director, because he'd already
forced into retirement, Dulles, and he says he wants to get fully briefed in on the UFO
stuff.
Now this becomes important because I didn't know when I found out all that stuff, I didn't
know about this other thing.
Yeah, the Harold Malmgren stuff.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
So yeah, he asked to get briefed about UFOs and wants to know more.
And this is really an important fact.
John McCone, before he became director of the CIA, after Dulles departed, was also the
lead of the Atomic Energy Commission.
He ran the Atomic Energy Commission.
So he definitely would have been privy to all of the secrets when it came to UFOs, given
the nuclear connection.
Yes.
Yeah.
And so he's asking for that.
And then I can give you the little Malmgren piece, which is, so Malmgren, Harold Malmgren
was a presidential advisor for JFK.
He was the youngest of presidential advisors.
He was one of McNamara's whiz kids and McNamara's secretary of defense at the time.
Malmgren is 27 years old, and he's in the Situation Room around the Cuban Missile Crisis.
And at that same time, the Cuban Missile Crisis, McNamara had put him in charge of cost assessments
for these new X-ray-based missile defense systems.
And so they're doing these tests in the Marshall Islands, specifically at Johnston Atoll, and
you have these test series.
There's a series called Starfresh Prime Tests.
And one of the tests is the Bluegill series.
And this is this kind of X-ray projection in the nose cone of these ICBMs meant to take
out incoming nuclear warheads, which we didn't have great nuclear defense at the time.
And so this was this really exciting experimental thing, and the RAND Corporation had a paper
on it actually earlier.
And so Harold is in charge of doing all the cost assessing for this.
Yeah, right.
And he catches wind that in this test, a UFO gets knocked out of the – comes out
of the plume of the nuclear blast.
And he freaks out, and he says, well, I need to know about this.
And they used to call them tagalongs at the time because they were so kind of immune to
– or it was so casual.
And Cold War kind of intensity was so – I don't know, it kind of just made them think
it was just – yeah, like normal thing that you have a UFO coming out of a nuclear blast.
Yeah.
And they just went out of the plume.
And he said, I need to know.
I have like all – I blink at Q clearances.
And they said, no, you don't.
This is Office of Naval Intelligence and the Atomic Energy Commission stuff or whatever.
And so they say, okay, you can know, but you have to come to Sandia Complex, Kirtland Air
Force Base, Sandia, where Lawrence Preston Geis, who's the maternal grandfather of Jeff
Bezos, can show you these UFO – they didn't say, we're going to show you these UFO pieces.
We'll brief you on it.
Yeah.
And then he goes.
They show him the UFO pieces.
He feels the debris.
The debris.
He feels this anomalous debris.
It speaks to him telepathically, which is remarkable.
Then he insists on getting briefed or he – I don't know, maybe Bissell reaches out to him.
But Richard Bissell, who was number two – went on to become number two at the CIA, but at
the time he was deputy director of plans at the CIA and he was known as the mayor of Area
51, goes and briefs him on, quote unquote, other world technologies.
Yeah.
And all of these kind of past crash retrievals, including Magenta of 1933.
And so Malmgren knows about this stuff.
And then JFK, I think a couple of weeks later, a few weeks later, ends up at Los Alamos getting
briefs.
Flying in.
Getting briefs.
Yeah.
So it's like, is that a coincidence?
Probably not.
Well, what it is, is that then Kennedy realizes that if he can give this information to Khrushchev,
that'll seal the deal, that Khrushchev will know that he's completely – he's dropping
this kind of nationalistic competitive thing with Russia and that they can have a genuine
joint space program.
And of course, they need to know about what this extraterrestrial dimension is if they're
going to be venturing out into space together.
But what happens is when he demands the briefing from McCone, Bissell and the other guys tell
Dulles about it.
Because Bissell and Angleton and the other guys kept going over to see Dulles all the
time in the brownstone over in Georgetown because he never left town.
He just stayed right there.
Because the fact of the matter is, is that the reason he'd been appointed to be the first
civilian director of the CIA is the fact that he was legal counsel for Brown Brothers Harriman.
This is Dulles.
That's Dulles.
Allen Dulles.
And that's where the China lobby is.
That's the group of people that had decided long ago.
That what they would do is secretly fund the rise of Hitler in Germany after World War
I.
Through the Union Bank.
The Union Bank and all that stuff that they set up to have them be raised up to be
the bulwark against Bolshevism in Europe.
And since the investors at Brown Brothers Harriman, these two dozen-
And that was the initial feeder for the CIA, came out of the Brown Brothers Harriman.
That's right.
It was Robert Lovett who actually wrote the initial memo.
Mm-hmm.
To Truman, saying, we've got to re-institute a major agency like the OSS, we gotta have
it in peacetime.
Mm-hmm.
And it came from Robert Lovett, senior partner at Brown Brothers Harriman.
And so that whole group was the seat of the China lobby, who saw the future of investment,
you know, capital investment in the Asian markets, because they already owned a controlling
stock interest in most of the war industry in Germany.
Mm-hmm.
Which they'd extracted through the Versailles Treaty Agreement, long involved in the process
they did it.
Mm-hmm.
But the bottom line is that when, at the end of World War I, at the end of World
War I, when the Treaty of Versailles was being signed, Robert Lansing, who was the Secretary
of State under Wilson-
Dulles' uncle.
Yeah, was the uncle of Allen and John Foster Dulles.
Right.
Mm-hmm.
And John W. Foster.
Who was the maternal grandfather for both Allen and John, John Foster.
So there was John W. Foster was the guy, and he was an arch imperialist.
Mm-hmm.
He's the guy that overthrew under his, when he was Secretary of State, he overthrew
the islands of Hawaii and started taking Guam and that whole thing, focusing on moving into
Asia.
Wow.
That was the whole idea of that.
Mm-hmm.
And what they did in the Versailles Treaty, he got Robert Lansing, who was the son-in-law
of John W. Foster, had Robert Lansing, his son-in-law, bring his two grandsons, John
Foster Dulles and Allen Dulles, with him to the Versailles Treaty, and actually as
lawyers at Sullivan and Cromwell, to draft into the Versailles Treaty Agreement the war
reparations requirements.
Whoa.
That Germany had to pay war reparations-
Mm-hmm.
... for all the damage they'd inflicted on other industries.
So that made them dependent on the Union Bank and American finance here.
Well, what happened was this was even pre-Union Bank.
This was in 1918.
Mm-hmm.
And so what they did is they said, look, that you're gonna have to pay these war reparations.
They imposed that financial obligation on them, but they didn't have the money to pay
them.
Mm-hmm.
And so what happened is the investors in Brown Brothers Harriman, these 20, 24 robber
baron families.
Mm-hmm.
The Rockefellers and Harriman Railway people and-
Carnegie and Mellon.
Carnegie and all of these guys.
Yeah, Mellon's.
All of them were there.
Mm-hmm.
And they saw their future as going westward into Asia.
Because what they could do is they could secure control over Europe through Germany.
Mm-hmm.
And what they would do is they would loan the money to Germany to pay the war reparations,
and they would take as security for their loans the controlling stock interest in like
a corrupt, ball-bearing factory.
Mm-hmm.
And IG Farben and all these other major war industries making the explosives and chemicals,
they would have this stock interest.
And a lot of these were kind of operation paperclip-based companies, right?
Like they were, in some cases, started and run by Nazis.
Right.
Well, the Nazis weren't there really yet.
Okay, okay, okay.
This is only 1918.
Okay.
Right?
And so what happened is what they did is they set up that mechanism by means of which the
stockholders or the investors in Brown Brothers Harriman-
Mm-hmm.
Called these two dozen wealthy, super wealthy families.
What they did is they had the controlling stock interest in those companies.
And then what they did is they additionally loaned additional money to Germany to rebuild
their war machine.
Mm-hmm.
So that they could be the bulwark against Bolshevism, because at the very end of the
First World War in October of 1917, the Bolsheviks had overthrown Tsar Nicholas II-
Mm-hmm.
And overthrown him and withdrawn them from World War I.
And so what happened is this seat of kind of a socialist alternative to the kind of
investment ideas that were housed at Brown Brothers Harriman, that they viewed them as
this terrible adversary.
Mm-hmm.
So what they did is they leaned in on Robert Lansing, who was the Secretary of State-
And sent a foreign military expedition into Russia that almost nobody knows about
it.
They had a full-scale U.S.-financed, U.S. military foreign expeditionary force-
Whoa.
What?
Into Russia-
In 1918.
Whoa.
To try to crush the Bolshevik Revolution.
Whoa, really?
And they recruited the white Russians, all those kind of Tsarist Russians that were
in St. Petersburg.
That whole crowd-
Was Dulles involved in it?
Dulles was involved with Germany.
Mm-hmm.
He was appointed to be the legal counsel for Germany.
As well as the legal counsel for Brown Brothers Harriman.
Whoa.
He was negotiating both sides of these financial agreements so that they had them
owning the basic-
He was the legal counsel for Germany?
For Brown Brothers Harriman.
But for Germany?
Is what it meant?
Yes.
He was appointed by Robert Lansing, his uncle, to be the legal counsel for Germany as well
so that he was on both sides of the negotiations.
He was counseling Germany to accept these loans-
Whoa.
You know, and to rebuild their war industry, and he ended up being basically almost the
legal governor general, you know, working for the German government.
Whoa.
And so that's what he did.
He choreographed that entire thing.
And so what happened is they got that all set up in 1918, 1919, then Robert Lansing
sent the foreign military expeditionary force into Russia to try to crush the Bolshevik revolution
in the cradle.
Hey, everyone.
Jesse here.
Let's talk about something a lot of us quietly deal with, hair loss.
This is something that messes with your confidence more than you'd expect.
Okay, you might be wondering, Jesse, you clearly don't suffer from this.
It's true.
The biggest issue I face is hat hair.
I actually have very thick hair.
But one of my good friends deals with hair loss.
So when iRestore sent me their iRestore Elite, I gifted it to him, and I've been amazed
at the results it gave him.
The first thing that stood out to him is it's comfortable and easy to use.
You just pop it on while reading or working, and it does its thing.
This isn't some gimmick.
It uses 300% of its power.
It has 100 lasers and 200 LEDs to deliver clinically backed red light therapy straight
to the scalp.
This is the best way to stimulate hair growth.
Over the past few weeks, I've seen noticeable improvement with my friend.
He says that his hair feels thicker and healthier, and it's improved his overall confidence
in life.
The iRestore Elite uses triple wavelength technology and Lumitech red light therapy.
It's engineered for deeper penetration and broader coverage.
That means more stimulation to hair follicles and better, faster results.
And look.
If it doesn't work for you, they offer a 12-month money-back guarantee.
I've never heard of a money-back guarantee that lasts that long.
Try it consistently, and if you're not happy, they get you your money back.
Of course, the restocking fee applies.
That made it a no-brainer for my friend.
So give yourself the gift of hair confidence this spring.
For a limited time only, our listeners get a huge discount on iRestore Elite when you
use code JESSE, J-E-S-S-E, at iRestore.com.
Head over to iRestore.com and get your free iRestore Elite.
If you want to support our show and tell them we sent you, you can go to iRestore.com
and use code JESSE, J-E-S-S-E, for our show's exclusive discounts on the iRestore Elite.
Please support our show and tell them we sent you.
Hair loss is frustrating.
You don't have to fight it alone, thanks to iRestore.
But let's get back to, okay, so 63.
So he's aware of UFOs and trying to do some joint space program with Khrushchev around
that.
Yes.
He is trying to defang the American nuclear arsenal, but also have...
Also the Russians.
Soviets.
Yeah.
The Russians.
And he's entirely a mutual disarmament.
Yes.
And he is trying to take the country back, the U.S. back from this kind of military.
And China agreed.
China agreed that they would not pursue any nuclear program at all.
Interesting.
Do we have records of that?
Yes.
Oh yeah.
Really?
Oh yes.
Where are the records of that?
They can dig them out because they reached out to China.
China only had like-
He reached out to Mao.
They had a real early interest in kind of...
Right.
trying to deal with the nuclear weapons issue but they hadn't really mounted a program and and he
agreed to forestall the entire thing really no way at that point at that point in between basically
january of of 1963 and june of 1963 at least prior to when when john the 23rd died that that was
still kind of a totally viable operation that they were planning to do uh and then when when
john the 23rd died i think uh kennedy leaned forward into it to try to to try to make sure
that the thing kept on going and so he decided he was going to get the information for khrushchev
and give it to him as a further sign of good faith so that they could not only
uh have a complete open and honest relationship by putting some skin in the game by coughing up
the information we had about this but also prepare for the who they were going to be encountering
you know out
in in extraterrestrial civilization you know and what happened is uh uh on june 5th when he asked
for it the bissel it's almost certainly was bissel you know found out about it you know and told
dallas and so dallas and the guys are really wait they can't allow the nuclear missiles to be
disassembled because they have to have them to deal with china you know because china had demonstrated
it already in the crew in korea that they could put a billion men in uniform and just melt your
gun barrels down by just pouring them on you like they did up at uh inchon and at the reservoir
you know that that's what they did they just sent in like a billion guys you know and just stormed
them uh and so they realized that they could not take on china in the future in a conditional land
war so they needed the nuclear weapons that's why macarthur kept saying what we got to do is show
bomb them you know that whole thing that fall out with truman so so the bottom line is that china
lobby freaked out about potentially losing their nuclear option against china so that can't be that
we can't allow that to happen and we can't wait a year for the elections you know i mean you know
they can probably figure out how to get rid of him in the election you know uh but they couldn't wait
the year because he would order to start ordering the disassembly and so what happened is that uh
that uh when he when on uh that june 5th that uh he ended up uh issuing the uh the the demand for
the he did the same thing same day he did this weird thing because i've never been quite figure
out yet about the printing these uh these silver certificates he did that on june 5th too he did a
whole bunch of these things i i met oliver stone once and he connects the printing of the silver
ifk assassination like that was somehow undermining of well he was he was doing a lot of radical
things right there yeah because i think that would happen was when when john the 23rd died
you know kennedy uh he was hoping to to bring uh john XXIII in and kind of catholic
support for what he was doing uh the ethics of what he was doing the whole speech at george
washington university and all that stuff you know he was going through this real metanoia
that time you know in the but the the act of disassembly and destroying the
nuclear warheads was viewed by Dulles in the guys as a as an act of treason you
know and now that but it was eliminating their ability to actually quell China
you know into to be able to have access to the market the Asian market so what
he did is just green lighted the s-force mm-hmm so this is this kind of sleeper
cell yeah they're just select group of traffic on day Cuban exiles who are
these kind of killer assassins that were originally the Commission's to take out
Che Guevara and Castro yeah and he re operationalizes them to take out JFK
she's all he had to do is just get up off their neck so who were the three who
were the they're the two men on the grassy knoll who were they well that what
we know that Morales was the shooter okay because he was the guy we we know
that the rip Robertson was there were they the two men on a grassy mole or
what was Morales on grassy knoll or Morales was on the grassy okay so he
took the shot from the grassy he took the shot from the grassy knoll wow that
was that was he Wow the the thing that I find to be in a certain sense so special
about what we now know that actually happened is the peculiar aspect of this
is the relationship that Oswald had with all these guys and then you look at the
what's come out about Oswald's landlady and he's this guy and he's this guy and
lady hmm she's a super curious character she's still alive bro she's like 93 no way ruth payne
is her name ruth payne that's right and she somehow was connected with dullis's mistress
bancroft am i making that up yeah no this is correct um she actually vacationed the summer
of 1963 at a place called nashon island which is right up near martha's vineyard in massachusetts
and nashon island is owned by the forbes family that's john kerry forbes the guy who ran against
bush in 2004 yeah right they're both skull and bones they both went to yale secret society
the forbes family hosted this summer retreat at their mansion ruth payne's there with alan
dullis allen dullis's mistress what they discussed is again that's not going to be in the jfk files
it's not going to be in the kennedy what year were they together there 63. that's so right there so
right after she leaves the jfk files she's going to be in the kennedy files and she's going to be
in the kennedy files and she's going to be in the kennedy files and she's going to be
nashon island i think she either before she went to nashon or after she visits her sister
in virginia turns out her sister works for the cia that's that's come out whoa then she goes
picks up lee and marina in new orleans and dry and brings them to dallas gives them a home
hooks lee up with his job at the school book depository building which by the way the school
book depository building is an interesting it's owned by d harrell bird dry hole bird is uh
d harrell bird is a school book depository building in nashon island which is owned by
David Harold Byrd is his real name, but they call him Dry Hole Byrd because he was against
something called the oil depletion allowance. He's an oil man. And Kennedy wanted to get rid
of this oil depletion allowance, which would have made all the oil people have to basically pay a
ton of money. They wouldn't get this government tax break from Uncle Sam. So they all hated
Kennedy. They wanted him gone for that reason. That's why you have the big oil element. And
big oil goes back way long in history. There's a whole book by Daniel Yergin called The Prize.
And there's a Prize Part Two where he talks about the whole history of oil with John D. Rockefeller
and how he bought out all the railroads and would only ship his oil through the railroads. So he
could basically have a monopoly over the oil business because none of the other oil companies
could ship their oil because he owned all the railroads. And that's why in monopoly, you own
all the railroads. It's part of the game. And again, he shut all the business and competition
out. And they were eventually disbanded with the Antitrust Act.
That's-
That broke up all the monopolies, supposedly. But a lot of these oil people have a real
dangerous history of murder and conspiracy going way back to then and just doing terrible things.
So yeah, those guys are involved. And then D. Harold Byrd, in addition to being an oil man,
he also buys a bunch of stock in this company called LTV, Ling Temco Vought. And he owns this
big share in Vought Aerospace. Well, it turns out Vought Aerospace,
built all the flying saucers for Wright-Patterson in the 40s and 50s under a guy named Alfred C.
Loading. Wait, wait, what? Yeah.
Really? Yeah.
We've built, what do you mean? When you say built the flying saucers, like built the Avrocar project,
which is on record as flying saucers? Well, the Avrocar project was Canada. So that was-
But then it got moved to Wright-Patterson as Project Y or Silverbug.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
But like, so when you say built flying saucers, because-
So the Vought Flying Pancake is a Vought aircraft. And it's literally an attempt,
it's an early attempt to build a Vought aircraft. And it's literally an attempt to build a Vought aircraft.
It's an early attempt to build a Vought aircraft. And it's literally an attempt to build a Vought aircraft.
It's an early attempt to build a flying saucer with propellers.
That was before Avrocar in the 40s. Yeah, it was way before. This was even predates that.
That's so interesting. I hadn't even heard of this. That's so, wow.
Yeah. It's very obscure. It's not well known. And then LTV, Ling Tengco Vought, he gives a bunch of
money with Ling, and they invest in this right before the Kennedy assassination. And of course,
aerospace and all those people made a ton of money off the Kennedy assassination.
And then you have deep space, aerospace-
Connections, deep state aerospace connections to Lee Harvey Oswald, because he worked at Atsugi,
which is where the CIA was running the U-2 spy plane program.
Whoa.
You know, so.
Well, also, I believe Harold Bird, who owned the Texas Book Depository,
he was, I think he had some connections with LBJ.
And then he was also connected with Curtis LeMay. Curtis LeMay gave him an award for the Civil Air
Corps when he was younger. And Curtis LeMay hated JFK.
Absolutely.
Hated him.
Hated him. And, you know, thought that he was, you know, kind of a traitor.
LBJ too. And there's pictures of LBJ and D. Harold Bird together, like going to football games. And
they were good friends. So they definitely knew each other. Definitely.
Maybe the craziest thing of all, I mean, JFK, we're painting a picture of him just being 360
surrounded by these like, you know, spooky people. The mayor of Dallas was a guy named Earl Cabell.
Yeah.
And his brother-
Charles.
Charles was Dallas's number two at the CIA.
And the Bay of Pigs.
There you go.
Yeah.
And Earl rerouted JFK's motorcade.
So like that.
They took it right by D. Harold Bird's building.
Right in D. B. Plaza.
It's like, come on. Yeah.
Now it gets even deeper.
It does here.
Yeah.
It's crazy, bro. Because, you know, D. Harold Bird, you know that he has, he's a big hunter,
right? He went, after JFK got assassinated, he went to Africa on a safari and shot a bunch of elephants,
brought their heads back and had them mounted on the wall in his big trophy room.
A big trophy room full of all the animal heads that he, of all the animals he killed and shot.
Yeah.
You know what else he did?
He took the window out of the 6-4 depository building and he put it in his trophy room at his house.
What?
Why?
What reason for that?
No way.
That's crazy.
That's fucking weird.
Whoa.
That is like, dude, that's red flags.
That is huge, huge red flags.
And the fact that Ruth Payne knows D. Harold Bird, she brings the Oswalds to Dallas, gives them this house to live in.
And then all after the assassination, they go to Ruth Payne's garage, find all the evidence that,
and then about a month after the assassination, after the FBI has already searched the home extensively,
Ruth Payne comes and says, oh, me and Marina found this other note that he left for Marina,
supposedly where he wrote Marina a note when he supposedly went to go shoot General Walker and left her a note.
But they found this.
That's all after the case.
And then they've used that to blame the shooting of Edwin Walker on Lee Harvey Oswald.
He's killing this anti-communist general, which is really weird because it doesn't make sense with the narrative of, what is he, just trying to kill someone to get famous?
Is that who we think Lee Harvey Oswald is?
The people go, oh, poor Oswald was just this innocent guy who was just a weirdo and he was just a fall guy and didn't have anything to do with it.
That's not true at all.
He was CIA trained.
Well, he was actually trained by the Office of Naval Intelligence.
It wasn't CIA.
Interesting.
And he was in this thing called Operation Redskin.
It was a whole different operation.
But the bottom line is he ended up being part of this thing that was called the Field Intelligence.
And it was a kind of a private spying operation, a political spying operation that was going on.
The William D. Pauley and Hunt.
E.H. Hunt.
And a lot of guys, they were funding it.
And that was Willoughby, George Willoughby, Charles Willoughby, rather.
Because when Truman got not fired, Truman wasn't fired.
He was re-deployed.
So what were these operations Lee Harvey Oswald was involved in?
He was doing spying.
He was doing spying on progressive groups around New Orleans, working with Guy Bannister.
It was true.
Guy Bannister is the FBI guy who's known as like that.
Head of the X-Files, like he's on the weird desk of the FBI.
Yeah.
And so he was 555 Camp Street.
Is that right?
Yeah, 555 Camp Street.
And so Lee Harvey Oswald is working out of that building.
That building mysteriously gets burned down, right?
By Novell.
Gordon Novell is the guy that was arrested and prosecuted by James Garrison in New Orleans
for burning down 555 Camp Street, the office.
Where?
Where Lee Oswald had the office, along with the guy that was the hardcore right wing guy
that was the head of the Latin American Anti-Communist League, the guy that was the former FBI guy
that was down in New Orleans.
The heck was that guy's name?
But anyway, he had an office in the exact same building.
On the exact same floor.
Whoa.
With him.
And Gordon Novell was prosecuted and convicted for burning down that building in the midst
of the investigation.
That's crazy.
Okay.
Who ends up later in the UFO conversation.
It's Novell.
You know, in means of working.
Who tried to hire me as his lawyer.
Robert Bigelow and stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So this is all so crazy.
Yeah.
So what is Lee Harvey Oswald doing exactly?
He's inserting himself into like...
He is, in addition to spying on the different liberal groups like ACLU and other things
that he's doing, filing reports with this field intelligence operation going on, that
what he's doing is he's infiltrating the Free Cuba group and pretending to be a Marxist,
you know, just like when he went to Russia and did all that stuff.
And so what he was doing is he was designing a character of being...
Involved with Russia and with Cuba.
And what the plan was is to coax him into taking a shot at the motorcade, not hitting
anybody, but taking a shot at the motorcade.
And then he would escape, but they would have...
They'd figure out who it was.
There's the gun and there's who he is.
And that they would blame it on Cuba and they could get back to invading the island.
You know, again, it was the same guys, the same hardcore right-wingers.
Right-wing guys that are into this.
And so he's all put into place to take this shot at the motorcade and then run and escape.
And what happens, he takes the shot at the motorcade, hits the curb and chips the curb,
the pieces of the cement flying, and immediately these other shots ring out and kill the president
right in front of him.
So you think Oswald missed?
Oh, he didn't miss.
He wasn't intending to hit him.
He wasn't even...
What was the point, really?
The point was...
The point was to have a shot fired at the motorcade to be a bungled attempt to assassinate
the president and blame it on Oswald, who was a Cuban operations guy, so that they could
then justify invading the island.
Yeah, got it.
Because that was the whole plan, a very subtle plan.
And he was involved in that part.
And when he fired the shot...
Why didn't they end up using him as, oh, like he was this Cuban operative?
Because that didn't end up being the narrative.
Like, we need...
We need to retaliate against Cuba.
Well, because he killed Tippett.
The police officer.
Tippett was sent to kill him, you know, because the whole idea is there's a dead guy.
There's a lone gunman, dead guy, you know, that he took the shot at the president.
You rotten bastards.
Got it.
You know, you're a Cuban, you know, spy and, you know...
And what was his association with Cuba prior?
He was part of the Free Cuba group.
He infiltrated the group.
That was when he got arrested on the street.
Remember?
By, you know, sitting on the street corner championing Cuba.
What year is this?
In 1963.
Okay.
1963.
And he's chanting Free Cuba, like, in New Orleans or where?
In New Orleans.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is amazing.
So he was creating this character who was kind of a zany guy who'd been to Russia and was favoring Cuba.
Yeah.
And he thought he was supposed to help get escaped.
The whole theory was they were going to help him escape, but they were going to blame it on him,
but he's already in some safe haven.
But in reality, they were just going to take him out.
They were going to kill him.
And then he killed Tippett.
That's right.
And then he sort of fumbled the plan.
As soon as he saw Tippett, he just killed him.
Wow.
And he got arrested for it.
You know, and so that's why he kept saying, wait a second, I'm just a patsy here.
Something's wrong.
I like some legal representation, but these police officers have not allowed me to have any.
I don't know what this is all about.
I'm a black guy.
How'd you get the black guy?
Sir?
Did you shoot the president?
I work in that building.
Were you in the building at the time?
Naturally, if I work in that building, yes, sir.
Back up, man.
Did you shoot the president?
No, they're taking me in because of the fact that I live in the Soviet Union.
I'm just a patsy.
And he tried to place the call.
He asked for the telephone call to Nag's head, which is Redskin.
That was the whole operation where he was dipped.
He was dipped.
Ship dipped.
He was erased.
And so the bottom line in that whole thing, the role of him, you know, it really disappoints
half of the Catholic community.
The Kennedy assassination community, oh, no, wait a second, he's supposed to be a completely
innocent guy, didn't have anything to do with it, you know, wasn't involved with these people
at all, and they're just these weird things, you know, that Garrison in New Orleans was
way off base, but he wasn't, you know, that that whole crowd was part of that, you know,
and Guy Bannister and that whole crowd.
Bannister was the head of the Central American chapter of the World Anti-Communist League.
Wow.
You know?
You know, that's who they are, you know, and that's what he was part of, and so that's
how the thing came down, and of course, as soon as it happened, all the people that knew
about the S-Force said, holy shit, it's the S-Force.
You know, there's Rip Robertson, photographs of Rip Robertson, who's the field operations
commander for the S-Force, standing right there in Dilley Plaza.
You got Ed Lansdale, you know, the photographs of Lansdale.
Ed Lansdale's sitting right there, and his wife identifying him, you know, and so you
got the S-Force is in town.
Wow.
I mean, you see Felipe Fidel Santiago on the grassy knoll.
This guy's like a radio man.
He looks like a Cuban.
He's out of place, and he's sitting right next to the umbrella man, and the umbrella
man's never been really solved.
They came out with this guy they said was the umbrella man in 74 at the House Select Committee.
That's not the dude.
Come on, now.
There was a different guy there with the umbrella symbolizing.
You didn't have the umbrella of the air support to help with the Bay of Pigs, and now we're
going to get you, and also being the signal man on the grassy knoll.
Did you know that there were three yellow painted lines right on the side of the curb
where the shot, in conjunction, where all the shots took place in the kill zone, and
they were painted the night before, because Beverly Oliver was standing on one.
She can be seen in the Zapruder film standing on the yellow curb on the edge of the sidewalk
on Elm Street, and she got yellow paint all over her shoe.
Because it was freshly painted the night before.
Now, there's no parking on Elm Street, so there's no reason to paint the curb yellow.
Everyone knows there's no parking there.
It's an on-ramp to the freeway, to the Stemmons Freeway.
You know, nobody pulls over there and parks, so there's no reason to paint the curb unless
you're marking the shots for the kill zone.
Were there any other actors or people worthy of consideration as far as the involvement here?
Yeah, I mean, the question is to how many of the people in,
you know, the Brown Brothers Harriman had to sign off on this, you know, other than Dulles.
And the real power was sort of in Sullivan and Cromwell, that whole law firm.
You know, that's not a normal law firm, Sullivan and Cromwell.
There was legal counsel for Brown Brothers Harriman.
The Cromwell of Sullivan and Cromwell is the guy that choreographed the overthrowing of
the Panamanian government to build the Panama Canal.
I mean, it was sort of like Williams and Connolly.
Interesting.
Yeah.
You know, it's not like a normal law firm.
Gotcha.
You know, that's like Sullivan and Cromwell was back at those times.
So the bottom line is that's what happened.
And then as soon as the people realized what had happened, they said,
shit, it's the S-Force.
You know, and so we got to do everything in our power to cover this thing up.
Because anybody finds out it's the S-Force, they're going to track it all the way back
through to the agency, and they're going to blame this on the agency.
Whereas it wasn't the agency as such.
Mm-hmm.
It was Dulles, you know, in his capacity as the consigliere, basically, for Brown Brothers
Harriman, you know, in that whole China lobby operation.
And so the agency went to great lengths to conceal this.
And then they briefed LBJ.
LBJ goes and gets a hold of Earl Warren and says, Justice Warren, Chief Justice Warren,
you've got to chair this commission because we've really got to quell any of these concerns
about a conspiracy.
And look at it.
One thing that you've got to do.
And he didn't want to do it.
And so he said, look, let me tell you why you have to do this, he said.
Because it says, you've got to be sure to conceal the fact that there was an assassination
team that was assigned to try to kill Castro.
And it was the Kennedys that put it together.
And if the word gets out that there was an assassination team that Kennedy put together
to try to kill Castro, everybody's going to believe that Castro found out about it and
killed the president.
And if that happens, you know, people are going to say, well, that's not true.
That's not true.
They're going to go crazy.
And they're going to try to make us invade Cuba.
And if we do that, Russia is going to cause a world war.
And they lie to Chief Justice Warren to get to chair the Warren Commission.
And they put Alan Dulles, who was the de facto guy that ran the Warren Commission, you know,
the whole thing, to cover them all up.
So crazy.
To cover them.
And what people do is people, when they get little pieces of the information,
they say, well, this is the agency that killed him.
Yeah.
You know, and they kill him because he screwed up the Bay of Pigs.
Did they get Jack Ruby to kill?
What happened with Jack Ruby?
I mean, that's all the mob.
They said, wait, holy shit, we've messed up here.
How did they manipulate Jack Ruby into killing Lee Harvey Oswald?
He was a made man.
He was a made man of the mob.
You know, when they tell you...
Do you think they MKUltured him because he says he didn't remember killing Lee Harvey Oswald for a long time?
No, I don't think that's true.
You don't think so?
That's just...
Okay, but so then, yeah, maybe not, you know, for the actual killing.
But then he ends up in jail and he claims that he doesn't remember killing Lee Harvey Oswald,
but is pretty lucid.
And then he's seen court ordered by a psychiatrist who is on record as being part of MKUltra,
a guy named Jolly West, who is letters between him and Sidney Gottlieb.
We, you know, are fairly sure that he was involved in CIA mind control stuff.
And he sees Jack Ruby for 24 hours.
Totally not filmed, you know, and comes out.
Jack Ruby has a psychotic break.
And he starts, you know, saying that there are Jews outside his jail cell screaming or whatever,
and is never the same after that.
And Jolly West does a press conference saying Jack Ruby has gone crazy.
You know, he's lost his marbles or whatever.
And so...
So he can't depend on anything he says.
Yeah.
I mean, that's got to be pretty...
But that would imply that the first time around he wasn't MKUltra
because maybe he had some...
He had something to share and they needed to scramble his brain to cover it up.
The thing is, is that just following Occam's razor,
you get a real simple line and narrative of what really happened.
And then all kinds of activities that are undertaken to cover up and conceal this,
you know, end up being interpreted as your principal involved in making the plan to kill him.
Because it makes...
It satisfies people's other more sinister worldview.
Right.
Yeah.
But...
But the bottom line is that the threat that was going to come unraveled happened with the Watergate burglary.
Because what happened is when, as soon as the Democratic National Committee chooses Larry O'Brien...
Yeah.
...to be the new head of the Democratic National Committee,
it turns out previously, 20 years, he was the chief lobbyist for Howard Hughes in Washington.
This is an amazing part of your narrative,
which is that Larry O'Brien is the number two or...
...the chief lobbyist for Howard Hughes.
Howard Hughes was responsible on behalf of Nixon for setting up, you know, the S-Force...
That's right.
...and working with Trafficante.
Yep.
And so Nixon is...
Because he was a longtime political opponent of JFK, is freaked out that he's...
Because he's running for president later.
Yes.
Is in the...
You know, so this is in the 70s.
He says...
He's freaked out that basically Larry O'Brien is going to out him as having killed his longtime political opponent.
Yeah.
Even though he set up the S-Force not to kill JFK.
That's right.
To kill Castro.
It was to take out Castro and Che Guevara.
That's right.
But he's freaked out that they have compromise on him.
And if you look at what happened in the Watergate scandal, the burglary...
That's right.
It's James McCord is involved.
You represented him.
Yes.
You know, in the one afterwards.
Yeah.
McCord was known as Dulles' number two and his favorite guy or whatever.
It was, you know, his favorite understudy.
Mm-hmm.
And they put...
They bugged Larry O'Brien's phone.
And bugged his office.
So clearly...
So clearly they were targeting him.
And Nixon was way up against McGovern in the polls in that election.
Oh, yeah.
So you always have to ask the question, was it like he was paranoid, but was he that paranoid?
Like, why would he do that if it weren't this sort of specific thing he was worried about?
That's right.
Because if O'Brien were to reveal the fact that he's the one that created the assassination
team that in fact killed the president, there's no way you can talk your way out of that in
time in an election year.
From June, between June and November.
Yeah.
He's not going to climb out from under that.
And so he said, we've got to find out whether O'Brien knows about it and is thinking at
all about using it.
So we've got to not only wiretap his telephone, but bug his office.
That's amazing.
And that's what they did.
And they sent him in to do it.
So you then are the lawyer for James McCord.
Well, it was Bailey.
It was Bailey himself.
Okay.
Because Bailey, it turns out, was on index four for the agency.
Which we didn't know.
Okay.
You know?
None of us knew it in the office.
Okay.
Did you...
Did you learn anything from those guys about, like, spooky intel world?
Or, like, did any of them sort of reveal any secret?
Like, McCord...
Did you interact with McCord at all?
No.
Okay.
But I knew that McCord was...
Didn't want to plead guilty.
He was refusing to plead guilty.
He said, why am I pleading guilty?
You know, that we got...
Because he had been told that they were going in to try to find evidence that O'Brien and
the other guys were coordinating and financing anti-war demonstrators.
Yeah.
And he wanted to get that information.
So he thought he was involved in kind of a typical kind of, you know, I guess, meat and
potatoes kind of covert operation by the agency.
And they've been instructed that if you get caught doing a covert operation for the agency
stateside, which is totally illegal, call one of the people on the index four.
You know, there's William Bennett Williams.
And then there's...
There's Bailey.
And there was this other guy, Miller, I knew about.
You know, but I didn't know any of that when Bailey contacted me and asked me to come over
to his shop to be special counsel, you know, for the burglary case.
I want to pivot slightly.
It's the same sort of, you know, world that we're talking about here.
But you have a very interesting narrative about how some of maybe the initial financing
occurs for secret covert UFO programs in America.
Oh, yeah.
And you talk about this Anderson Trust and, you know, billions of dollars worth of lost
gold.
$1.2 trillion.
There you go.
At $32 an ounce.
Unbelievable.
Which is now $3,400 an ounce.
So what's the story there?
Well, what happened is back in about 2000, it was just like 2000, year 2000, that Mr.
Aiea, who is...
He's like the third richest fellow in the entire Philippines, you know, contacts the
Jesuit headquarters that he wanted to have somebody from the Jesuit headquarters because
he'd gone to a Jesuit high school and college and stuff and wanted them to come and brief
the top 50 business people in the Philippines about what the consequences of global climate
change were going to be for the island, you know, with the rising sea levels is going
to swamp parts of the island and ruin businesses.
And so trying to see if...
They would mobilize the business community to do something about it, right?
So I got designated to go brief him.
So I fly to the Philippines and Mr. Aiea puts me up in this like 20-star hotel, you know,
with this sumptuous food everywhere, all this bizarre kind of offensive kind of opulence.
And I go brief these guys and I tell them that what they should do is they should try
to mobilize and get the government.
The Philippines, which they had some influence with, these rich business guys, you know,
to lead the Association of Island States in the United Nations to mobilize a motion on
the floor of the General Assembly to have a uniting for peace resolution, to have the
island states all joined together and accuse the United States and China and India of aggressive
actions.
And so I told them, you know, if you can get two-thirds of all the members of the General
Assembly, the 193 countries at that time, you know, to support such a resolution, you
can get an investigation done.
And if you can get three-fourths of them to vote for a resolution ordering those countries
to start cutting down the island, you know, that's going to be a big deal.
What are you doing?
We can'tую it.
So we had a deal, okay?
And the resolution was the United States and China are considering coming back on all of
the use of petroleum.
And if you can come back on all of the use of petroleum, you can enforce it.
And the Security Council can't veto it, okay?
So I explained that all to them.
And then Mr. Aya drives me up to his big mansion on the top of the mountain overlooking
Manila.
And we're sitting there, you know, sipping lemonade in the afternoon.
And he said, you know, would you like to meet the president or the Senate of the Philippines?
And I said, yeah, that would be really helpful.
That's kind of neat.
could get right to them you know and he said well look at me let me get a hold of me he gets up and
leaves he goes in makes a call he comes back just good let's go down and see him so we go getting
his big Cadillac we drive down off the hill he walks into the to the office of the president
of the senate says hi to the secretary and we just walk in we sit down he introduces me to
senator Pimentel who is the president of the of the Philippine senate and I'm briefing him on this
how to go about you know spearheading organizing the association of island states to bring on a
motion under the uniting for peace resolution and he's he's listening to me but he doesn't
seem particularly enthralled about it all and so then he he casually gets up and goes over and he
closes the door and comes to sit back down he said well I should tell you he said as the president
of the of the senate you know I chair a thing called the blue ribbon commission and the blue
ribbon commission is charged with
finding these 176 troves of treasure that have been buried in the Philippines by general
Yakushima at the end of world war ii and each of them has like a hundred billion dollars of gold
and silver in the platinum bars and big 50 gallon drums of diamonds and rubies and precious jewels
that have all been pilfered by a special unit of the Japanese army that was deployed all during
the 19th century and they were all in the middle of the war and they were all in the middle of the
war and they were all in the middle of the war and they were all in the middle of the war and they
were all in the middle of the war and they were all in the middle of the war and they were all in the middle of the war and they
were all in the middle of the war and they were all in the middle of the war and they were all in the middle of the 1930s before world war
were all in the middle of the war and they were all in the middle of the war and they were all in the middle of the 1930s before world war ii started as a treasure a war chest for
the the war because they were and they were worried about being invaded or taken well they
yeah because they they knew that that once the germans had surrendered in may of 1945 it was
just a matter of time that the us was going to invade the island you know and and take them down
uh and so they they were going to move all of the the treasure out of there uh out of japan and
they're going to bury it and they were going to sign general yakushima himself to oversee all that
and they were going to send the uh the cousin i think of uh of uh hiroshito
you know uh to a prince a japanese prince of the royal family to accompany them so he would know
where all 176 of these treasure troves were and so they sent them into the islands and they started
moving the the gold out in the last months of the war and they buried it uh and they buried
them in these like you know like you know 500 600 feet deep you know
big wells like that they drilled and then they were using uh prisoners of war to do the digging
and then burying the team that dug that particular hole burying them with the gold so that no one
would know be around to tell where where did where did this gold end up it ended up in the philippines
there's 176 troves of these it's still there still there so there is 1.5 trillion or 1.2 trillion worth of gold
in the philippines now oh 1.2 trillion was just about just 12 of the troves there's 176 of them
and they're still there yes they're still there so who's guarding over them they they don't they
can't find them that's what the problem is they're crazy people running around the philippines for
decades trying to find these places no but they don't they don't know where they are but you but
we have documentation that there are a lot of these oh yeah the the marcos got two of them yeah
by by capturing one of the guys who was uh who who found one of them and they drilled the eyes
out of his son right in front of him with a hot poker marcos did colonel ver you know did it who
was who's marcos marcos was the president of the of the philippines whoa that uh that was who drill
who drilled the the general ver was his kind of chief torturer and uh he tortured this guy's son
right in front of him to get the guy to tell him where two of these little troves were
you know and uh they got two of them uh marcos got two of them each of a hundred billion dollars
what but but so what does this have to do with the ufo well no the it doesn't as such what what we
know is that that at the end of world war ii after they had done this after they buried them all
and there were maps of of them that what happened is that lansdale ed lansdale who was in the oss
when they disbanded the oss
after the germans uh uh surrendered in may of 45 that truman disbanded the oss and reassigned them
all around and ed lansdale who's an oss guy gets made the g2 uh in manila right and he knows about
the fact that this treasure has been buried around there and so what he does is when when general
yakushima turns himself in you know at the end of the war after the dropping the bombs you know in
in august the 6th and
8th of 45 you know they all surrender uh so there's not going to be any kind of uh invasion
to the but and what what uh japan was hoping that they could get a conditional surrender
uh and that they would be able to keep custody of the philippines
so that they'd be able to then later go in and dig these things up and have you know re
constitute the wealth of the japanese empire right that was the plan but the u.s bombs them instead
and says you know it's an unconditional surrender you don't get the philippines we keep the
philippines right and so and so what happens is is uh ed lansdale ed lansdale uh knows that these are
here and so these these treasure troves are there so what he does is he he kidnaps the driver for
general yakushima who would know where the some of them were right and so he has him tortured
this guy means santa maria
mario uh uh santo mario yeah it's his name uh this corporal that actually conducted the
torturing of this driver uh and they find out where 12 of the troves are so they punch the
first one uh and find the hundred billion dollars uh i've seen photographs of the i mean it looks
it's like a football stadium down underneath the ground you know that goes down like five
six hundred feet huge cave
down there and stacks of gold bullion you know you know armpit high as far as you can see you know
and big barrels of jewels everywhere and the bottom line is they they punch 12 of these things
and so uh so lansdale after punching the first one and verifying that that is for real he gets
in a plane he flies uh from manila to singapore to see macarthur and he goes in to see macarthur
tell him what they've got here right and macarthur brings in his g2 who's charles willoughby uh in the
and so macarthur orders willoughby to go with ed lansdale in macarthur's private plane
and they fly him from singapore back to manila back into the the philippines and back into the
united states right and they they go to see truman to tell truman that they've got 1.2 trillion uh in
gold bullion and platinum in uh in uh silver and jewels uh and the the chief of staff won't let
them see him uh unless he they tell him what they want to talk about so they brief the chief of staff
who is clark clifford so clifford comes into the meeting uh with truman uh with uh ed lansdale
and with willoughby and they start to brief truman about what they've got truman says hold a second i've
got to bring uh stimson in brings in the secretary of war stimson brings them in as soon as stimson
starts realizing what they've got he sends for his three deputies and he he brings in robert lovett
uh and robert anderson both not only deputy secretaries of war but senior partners
and brown brothers harriman and and john j mccloy and they bring them in the three deputies they
find out what they've got here and truman decides
that what he's going to do he's not going to tell anybody he's not going to tell the congress he's
not going to tell anybody else about it they're going to set up this secret uh trust that they
call the anderson trust they set it up down in houston texas and they they set up the the
anderson trust and they have all this and they they assign we we now know we've got the he's
still alive the the the commander of the pilot that flew the flew the gold out he's alive yes
he's alive have you spoken to him we know what i'm going to whoa we're going to we're going to we're
going to write where he is now and and i'm going to i'm going to talk to him you know to get this
thing on the record whoa but so that so they fly though using u.s military transport they fly these
these this gold all out of there you know these 12 troves of it and they bring it to the
international credit bank in geneva switzerland and then they deposit it there and then they issue
gold certificates on it which are like bearer bonds you know and they they make they distribute
them to right-wing
anti-communist candidates for mayors and stuff after world war ii you know all throughout europe
whoa and there's so there's this whole covert program so this has nothing to do with the ufos
no oh no no no no no but what it is is it's a it's a mechanism for secretly funding covert
operations yeah they're going on after world war ii uh when the cia is set up and they're
all funding this stuff and that's dallas knows about this money that's there yeah and so that
they're they're using this for covert operations interesting you know and yeah that's wild that's
wild it's it's it's totally uh separate from the the ufo stuff yeah yeah yeah i think chris ramsey
who just did a great interview with you yeah told me maybe he thought it had something to do with
ufos so no i'll use this as a uh opportunity to say chris why'd you lead me astray but go watch
your interview with chris because i thought that was great i don't know if you've seen it but it was
it was really great yeah i don't see i don't see most of these things i just you know when i yeah
with somebody that i trust anyway that i can just tell you yeah and so it's done there yeah i know
that you guys will tell other people check it out in area 52. um yeah in that interview you
actually talk about uh an interview with a live alien being yeah uh at s4 in area 51. that's right
and uh yeah you care to go into any detail around that well yeah i did i got a jesuit head
quarters uh i mean it must be about uh let's see when that would be uh it was 94 that i'd already
done the uh the john mack stuff uh so it was it was like 2000 uh 2001 2002 something like that
that uh i get a call uh from a guy uh in northern minnesota and he's uh on his death
well he's actually in hospice right uh and he wants me to come and see him there's something
and he says that he worked directly with project blue book and so i said uh oh uh uh okay
so i fly there and fly into minneapolis and rental a car and drive up into this little teeny town
up in northern minnesota uh and there he is he's at this little hospice place with he's got one of
these little rollers with all the little bottles on it and stuff in his nose and he starts telling
uh he was a uh a clerk typist army u.s army clerk typist assigned to this special unit of project
blue book that was focusing just on the 700 or so uh cases of of instance incidents which they
couldn't explain away they were just too credible the the sources were too credible they had too
many people had seen it what was his name that is his name was uh oscar uh wolf oscar
wolf or oscar lane oscar wolf yes oscar wolf uh-huh that's who he was uh and uh and uh he he
starts telling me about it all uh and it goes into detail about it uh now it's one of these bizarre
things because i my my office people said you've got to bring a camera you've got to bring a camera
to get this guy if he's going to give you a day did you record him yeah i i brought the little
thing i set it all up on the little table and then i put it on the table and i put it on the table and
and so i had the whole the whole thing recorded uh and it got corrupted somehow but i think jeremy
corbell might have recorded an interview with this guy separately later yeah he did and he also he
also talked with richard dolan okay so we have him on record that's right oscar and well they
but the thing is they didn't press into them as far as i know about this incident
oh really and he and he told me about the fact that he because i kept they missed the
they buried the lead well yeah because i was interrogating the out of him you know
i was just pressing down on him because i figured he was going to be a guy he's not just he's not
that bad so so yeah don't don't mess with me so yeah shape up you know he's just dying
i could have said you know if you want any absolution you know but i didn't do that part
so so so man the jesuits are thugs that's that's being too tough you know and so so so the bottom
line he tells me
that that that the reason that he has developed this kind of special relationship with the
commander of this unit that is assigned specifically to investigate the the uh the the
700 other cases right is because he and the commander were both part of this really fundamentalist
christian sect called the worldwide church of god i mean apparently really hardcore fundamentalist
crowd and and uh
and so that he he stayed there for years and when they were working on people would come and go in
the staff and do field investigations and all that but he kept staying there and keeping records and
then his commander comes in and said that he is going to be going to area 51 and uh wanted wanted
oscar to come with him and so he did he went with him but it turns out it was not just area 51 it
was s4 so they actually went all the way to s4 uh and went down in the big elevators and went in
and he said he saw like three or four by the way s4 isn't supposed to officially exist so it's
important the only versions where it exists you have bob lazar you have a guy named dan barish and
you have this story that's right and i think we're gonna get some more corroboration soon
that s4 does in fact exist and then then all of a sudden you start asking questions about
these specific stories and it starts to blow your mind okay so you're going down so so he
goes down and he says and he sees like there's three or four uh ufos that are
just they've got little like uh little garages like these these little chambers it's the same
story as bob lazar and they're just they're just hovering in there they're just so they were just
they're just hovering all by themselves inside these little garages like that were underground
he said he saw them uh and then they went in and his his commander was going to be quote interviewing
a live et guy right so he goes with him and they come into this other area where there were
military guys there he said but there was this room like a standalone room with these big two-way
mirrors that that you could see through uh from the outside and he said he saw the et guy but he
was like you know five and a half feet tall no wasn't a little tiny short guy it was a kind of a
kind of life-size guy
big big head big eyes and he was in this kind of jumpsuit that they'd provided for him
uh and he was he was very cooperative that he wasn't being interrogated speaking english or
no no he was it was all telepathic it was all telepathic they just he just saw them sitting
across from he could see he could see his commander walk in but he wouldn't go because he
said he said i thought it was demonic that's what he said he said i thought it was demonic and i
didn't want to go near him and so he stayed outside and but he could see his his commander
having this kind of telepathic communication going on with him and his commander was a
fundamentalist christian yeah yes and so how what was the communication like that that he didn't say
he just said that was telepathic he could tell that they were having this telepathic well he
probably afterwards got it confirmed by his his commander that it was all telepathic they weren't
talking you could just see that they were having this kind of communication did he seem honest to
you oh yes oh yes so you think that happened yeah
i do think that happened i think that happened you know and uh so you think we have alien beings
at s4 well no no all i all i know is i think that there was one there okay at that time
at that time and that he saw him uh and that he he stayed outside and the the military guys that
were there showed him these these cards they had he said they had these index cards that
and it didn't say whether they were typed up or printed but they had the
questions and answers that were there of things they'd ask him right and so they had a little
record of interviews that have been conducted with him and then one of them he said that uh
they asked him you know so where are you guys from what are you what are you doing
here and he said that you know he was part of a group uh of people beings from different star
systems in our galaxy he said and that their job was to go around monitoring
where life had started in different planets inside the galaxy uh in that that was what they did
and that's what they were doing here and he said they asked him well who's who tasked you to do
that you know who's in charge of that he said well it's what you people would refer to as god
but it's very different than you think then how is it different he didn't say he said but i didn't
believe him
he said because i thought he was demanding so i never told anybody
i never told anybody about this have you ever heard the term collins elite yes
do you think that the this kind of fundamentalist christian commander was involved in the collins
elite no it didn't didn't seem to be this is kind of an individual thing with him and
this guy because they also thought that the the alien stuff was kind of demonic oh yeah no no
that there's there's a whole a whole stream of that in the fundamentalist world you know i've
got you know that sarah's uh sister-in-law fundamentalist you know and she will she
thinks the whole thing is demonic and then that's it's a it's a meme have you ever interviewed i
mean i'm sure part of it is and part of it might be angelic and you know it's like probably i think
that is because people don't understand that whole part people don't understand angelic it's probably
good and bad is probably way too simplistic of a frame for whatever they're operating on and i'm
sure they're good ones that incidentally do violence to you because of their kind of you
know field or whatever once you you know it's like saint prince saint francis of assisi has a vision
of this you know um kind of you know winged angel being it was a flaming torch in the original
translation but as a seraphim and it does violence to him but it's like it's that becomes part of his
conversion towards god and it ends up sort of killing him but
you
i think the sort of good bad you know dichotomy is probably a earthly one that yeah well there's
there's i mean an awful lot of uh anthropomorphic projection you know onto these folks because
they because they're so much like us i mean you know that that's a real challenge have you ever
met an alien no would you want it no sure really sure yeah i'd like to sit down and and chat with
them yeah and and actually figure out you know how to kind of
represent us yeah you know in in a full way about good and bad stuff that we do all of us
you know but try to figure out what the criteria are for trying to establish a relationship of
trust with them and how we could trust them what can they do to kind of assuage the concerns that
people have about them yeah in their kind of secretive ways you know have you ever seen
so you've seen picture of a ufo which was in the blue book file
and a skiff in dc and you even um it wasn't a skiff though oh it wasn't a skiff okay it was
just it was just this room that they had downstairs in the madison and you traced
the uh symbols symbols that were along the edge of the craft i did that um have you ever seen
anomalous material no i've seen photographs of the of this thing that hal had i've seen
photographs what thing that i had that piece of metal that's got like 17 different layers of
of different
is that magnesium bismuth yes yeah yeah i've just seen the layers thinner than a micron or
whatever yeah that's right that's the one i've seen photographs what do you think of you know
how put offs this sort of godfather architect of the space he's just uh you know seems to have his
hand in everything um what do you think of hal and his role and kind of ufology i think i think
hal is uh is more knowledgeable uh in depth
about this whole thing than most any of the people that you would meet you know can and know
uh you know in the that uh do you think he says everything he knows no oh no no he doesn't even
pretend to uh-huh no he doesn't even pretend to say everything he knows do you think he's worked
on a craft or seen a craft oh i'm sure he has you're sure he has no i'm completely sure he
really yeah do you think he knows how they fly no he has a better idea of how they fly
than most anybody you know there may be some technicians that that know more about some
details do you think he understands a lot about sort of um i don't know uh the mental networks
and that sort of thing do you think he's sort of clued into that oh yeah oh i mean that that's his
major focus from stargate is is yeah what's the connection between remote viewing and you know so
you had these guys in the remote viewing program like stargate you know which was formed by the
cia and later running out of the dia 1972 he um you know that some of these guys like ingo swan
would like remote view alien bases on the moon and things like that but do you think i talked to
ingo about it did you yeah i spent like a whole day with ingo no way apartment in new york what
what did ingo say about the alien bases it was interesting that that that my my access to him
came through the church of scientology thing you know that that's a big deal
yeah uh that church assigned that helped put off in church of scientology and in the uh uh targ russell
targ was church of scientology all kinds of the guys were and to catch people up you kind of won
l ron hubbard's favor by uh you know there was a case against them around uh you know special
exemption you know as a as a religious organization and uh there were you know i think they were they
were being bugged for a little bit and they were sort of trying to plug the federal government they
were trying to attract the federal government they had they had
they had the door of their headquarters chainsawed off right by the by the irs and then you and fbi you
were sort of helping them out and then you made it you were about to like sign on formally as their
counsel and then you asked them for their no no that wouldn't be the way to look i was asked to
be there you were asked to be there and i said look as a condition precedent to even begin to
talk with ron hubbard because he wanted to meet with me and try to persuade me to become the
lawyer for him and his wife specifically
not necessarily for the church but for him and his wife uh and that uh the the head guardian
from the from north america came to my office at the jesuit headquarters and said that uh that uh
mr hubbard would like to talk with you about becoming the lawyer for him and his wife susan
and i said well i said look as a condition precedent to even being willing to meet with
him to talk with him i'd have to be given permission to have access to whatever records
or information there is anywhere in the world about the church uh and i said that's i assume
that's a total non-starter right and they give you their records within a week they came back and
said it's a deal no way what do you want to see and so you could query anybody's e-meter results
anything i could get anything i wanted and so uh they flew me down to uh to florida uh and the big
blue cube they've got down there this big huge blue building uh and uh so i go in and there's the
head of the guardian's office
the u.s guardian's office and the international head of the guardians you know out of the uk uh
and they say uh so what do you want to see and i said uh well first what i want to see is the file
you've got on me uh in the american guy said no white no we've got i don't know and i said excuse
me i said what do you think i fell off some melon wagon somewhere i said you know you're gonna have
me to be l ron hubbard's attorney and you don't have any file on me at all and the international
guy said you're gonna have me be l ron hubbard's attorney and you don't have any file on me at all
yeah go get him the file you know so they bring me the file i'm going how deep was it how much
stuff did they have well they had they had you know pictures of me what was i you know i was
i was a jesuit candidate i was at the headquarters you know they were following me around they showed
me in different restaurants you know and meeting with people you know mark lane and some of the
other guys you know they said mark lane he was like uh kennedy assassination yeah yeah yeah
rush to judgment he was the author of that you know so you know they had all these kind of things
and so i said okay good i just wanted to make sure that it was that it was
that it was accurate you know and then so the international guy says me so okay so what else
do you want to see i said i want to see the three most sensitive files in the entire world according
to you as the head of the guardian's office you know and he just went oh he said i said so
so either you get him or not you know so he gets up and he's gone and revels is around comes back
and he ends up laying one of the files in front of me and i started looking at it and it was all
reported to me
reports by ingo swan now ingo swan was filing reports with the head guardian office in in the
uk about the entire internal operations of the office of naval intelligence uh remote viewing
program that they were doing he was just giving him all the information uh and he was a spy or
something yeah well he was a spy for the church of scientology for the church of science over and
against the office of naval intelligence why would he do that because he was a high level clear that
was his loyalty group
his loyalty he was loyal to them prior to that's right that's right over and above over because i
always i always thought put off was like looking into that stuff because he was like an nsa guy
before he was a scientology guy so i thought put off was just like tasked to like looking into this
you know very uh you know uh para governmental intelligence organization that is scientology
that's seen as a threat and so you know put get put off in there no this was a i mean the church of
science i mean the church of science is crazy you know it's just they're honest and they're
religious they're very honest but there's no i dont know they're not quite sure but they're
pro philae muita so uh i think there was a major confrontation with them between the uh the human
like people from the pleiades over against the reptilians from zeta reticuli and that there's a
major confrontation going on over which of them is going to actually assert
Do you agree with that, Worldview?
No, I don't.
But Swan was like fully in with the Scientologists and was giving them information
on the Office of Naval Intelligence?
All of it.
And so you're also saying that there's a remote viewing program that was deeper
than Stargate, because that wasn't Office of Naval Intelligence, that was DIA after
CIA.
No, this was a program, and Pat Price, I'll give you some idea how deep this goes, Pat
Price, you know, they had the file, Ingo Swan had the file that Pat Price had gotten so
good at remote viewing that they assigned him a task of, they gave him the exact longitude
and latitude down to the minute and second of a location, and he was assigned an artist
so that he didn't have to do these hand scratches trying to show it.
But he was, and he was saying, you know, so what's there?
So there's this major building here, and there's a big fence up with razor wire on the top
of it and everything.
And his facilitator was Russell.
Russell Targ.
And so Russell's saying, okay, now can you get inside the fence?
Can you see anything inside the fence?
And he goes, yeah, okay, all right, yeah, I can see inside the fence, there's just
this no man's land there.
Can you get to the front door of this place?
And he said, all right.
He said, okay, all right, I got it, yeah, okay, I'm in front of the front door.
He said, can you go inside the building?
And he said, let me see here, okay, yeah, yeah, I can see inside the building here.
And he said, so what do you see?
He said, there's this big long hallway.
And there's some doors on both sides, and Russell said, now go down to the third door
on the left.
And he said, okay, and he said, can you go into the room?
Yeah, I can go into the room.
So what do you see?
Well, there's a big desk there and chairs and stuff, there's a big file cabinet over
in the right corner over here.
Go over to the file cabinet.
He goes over to the file cabinet, there's a second drawer, first file, read it to him.
And he did.
What was it?
Well, that's not the point.
The point is that he did it, and he can do it.
It turns out it's an American facility, it's a top CIA security facility, and he penetrated
it.
That's insane then.
So anybody with remote viewing skills can get the nuclear codes?
Not anybody, but Pat Price could.
The best.
So that's Pat Price, right?
And in the same file, it points out that Pat Price had actually evolved to the point where
they could take a full photograph of a boomer class Russian submarine.
Nuclear submarine.
And show it to him and say, where is it right now?
And he would give them right down to the exact longitude and latitude, down to the minute
and second of exactly where that is.
And he visualized the whole thing and told them exactly where it was.
But there was a huge UFO right over the top of the water where that thing was.
And it was tracking it and monitoring it.
And he had it in the file.
I'm going, whoa.
I said, this is...
I said, this is pretty wild.
And then I said, OK.
So what else have you got?
You know, he says, well, here.
And he said, I said, show me the show me the second file and he showed me the second file.
And it was again from Ingo Swann.
It was a deep inside report from Ingo Swann that they had taken Pat Price in the program
up to southern Canada, south central Canada, just north of the state of Michigan.
And he was, he brought him to this little facility.
It was like this little domed little building.
And it had these big, huge dishes on top of these communication dishes on top.
And they brought him in.
And they set him down and they put this helmet on him and they had him think a particular
message.
And they turned all the antenna down to the northern peninsula of Michigan.
That was a big deal, that was a great deal.
And they took him to this mountain that was right on the first street of the state of
Michigan.
that little section that's in there, and had him be telepathically projecting, when it
comes time for you to file your US income tax forms next year, file them in this little
post office box down in this little town down in West Virginia, and 85% of the people did
it next year.
No way.
Absolutely way.
That's insane.
You keep saying that.
So you're saying that Scientology had some sort of mass mind control technique?
That wasn't the Church of Scientology.
What was it?
This was the program.
That was the program, the Office of Naval Intelligence.
But that's like, the implications of that are crazy, wouldn't you-
No, they're profound.
Yeah.
And so then I, from then-
So you met Ingo Swann.
Yeah.
I didn't say no to them then, but as soon as I saw the file on the fair game, I knew
I wasn't going to do it.
But I had the opportunity to go see Ingo.
Mm-hmm.
So I contacted Ingo and said, I'm being asked to be the lawyer for Hubbard, and I
want to chat with you.
So I went to see him at his apartment in New York, and we go all the way upstairs up onto
the roof of his apartment that he's got there, and then I started talking to him.
And I didn't want to freak him out over the fact that he was clearly violating his security
clearance-
Mm-hmm.
... by providing these reports to the-
Yeah.
... the Church of Scientology.
So he was using his remote viewing from Stargate in the reports that he was giving to the Church
of Scientology.
Yeah.
He was filing not only about his work, but Pat Price's work, the other stuff, all the
things that he was doing, he was reporting to the Guardian.
So he's basically like, he was a back-channel spy to the Church of Scientology-
Yeah.
... on behalf of them, vis-a-vis the federal government of the US.
It was clearly his major-
Allegiance.
... loyalty-
Wow.
... allegiance was to them.
Did you ask him about, because he wrote a book called Penetration about-
Yes.
... seeing bases, alien bases on the moon.
Yeah.
I hadn't seen that at the time.
You hadn't seen that?
No.
Did you get into the alien thing at all with him, or-
Oh, yeah.
Because-
What did he say?
Because he, in one of his reports, had a report in there about, it was Hal Puthoff,
no, it wasn't Hal.
It was Targ, Russell Targ, had been facilitating a remote viewing by Pat Price when they stepped
it up from him being able to remote view things in real time to be able to be shown a photograph
of a Russian Boomer submarine, and then he could locate it.
He could figure out exactly where it was, down to the minute and second.
Longitude and latitude, I mean, which was the big deal, you know, I mean, that's the
big deal.
Yeah.
And when they found it, when they found it and verified that it was there through
the remote viewing, others to find it, there was a UFO hovering right over the top of where
the Russian Boomer submarine was going into the water, and it was monitoring it.
And I just, when I saw it, I just went, whoa.
Did you see a photo?
No.
Okay.
No, they just told me about it.
It was a written report that it was there, and it was just, it was following right along
where the Russian Boomer submarine was going, you know, and that was the only piece that
was in there, except when I started interrogating people, you know, because I wanted to get
as much advantage as I could of the opportunity that I had here to get information.
So I got to meet the guy who was legal counsel for the church to ask him to explain to me,
you know, what the net-net of all this was, you know, what were they up to here?
And what it is is that they considered themselves entitled to being considered a sovereign entity
because the Catholic Church was.
So the Catholic Church has this kind of status of being a sovereign entity in a nation, basically,
because they have Vatican State, right?
So they insisted that as a matter of First Amendment equal protection, that they were
entitled to take unto themselves the same status.
And so that's what caused them to be engaged in this fair game program.
They believed that they had a right to engage in, like, wet operations, you know, like the
United States does and Russia does and all of that, which they asserted, you know, the
Vatican does, they said.
Do you think, do you think that the Vatican and that specifically maybe the Knights
of Malta had anything to do with the UFO kind of reverse engineering or transport or oversight?
I think that an element of the Knights of Malta have something to do with everything.
And why do you think that?
Because of the people that there were in this, this Monte Carlo group.
There's a thing called the Monte Carlo group that is at the top, top of the entire Knights
of Malta structure.
And I discovered that there were non-Catholics in it, which didn't make any sense to me at
all because the Knights of Malta is a Catholic men's club like thing.
But there's a, there's this high.
Yeah.
There was a Catholic executive council that turned out that Henry Kissinger was on it.
Uh, and, uh, and, uh, in George Bush senior was on it, who's Episcopal.
That's amazing.
Well, if I were, but if I were to play devil's advocate, I could've said council of foreign
relations Bilderberg, you know, like I could name five other organizations that those two
guys were a part of.
Yeah.
Um, any other reasons to believe they had something to do with the UFO?
No, just, no, just not specifically, but I'm saying is that anybody who is at the top of
at that level dealing with international things would have to be involved in this there's no way
that you're not going to be involved in this because i mean you could be involved in all
the other stuff and it wouldn't make any difference ultimately you know i mean this
whole thing could to use a phrase trump you know everything what is the is there kind of a mandate
or you know constitution for the knights of malta i mean the the only references i really have are
you know humphrey bogart the maltese falcon they were supposed to be the guardians of this
maltese falcon and i believe they're also the heirs to the hospitaliers you know there was the
kind of templars back in the day yeah sort of you know um pre-13th century when they were they were
disbanded i guess 14th century um and then they were kind of the guardians of these pilgrims that
would go to the temple mount in you know jerusalem and then the medic side of that was the hospital
and so that sort of there's some
lineage between that and you know knights of malta but otherwise i don't really understand
you know what they do i know they have sovereign status and they can kind of they do yeah they're
military they're a military order uh and they they're a sovereign they're a sovereign military
order uh and it's it's it's very clear that you know the guys like reinhard galen was in the
knights knights of malta he was a former nazi yeah reinhard galen is the guy that was the head
of the anti-soviet and anti-eastern black intelligence for the
third reich uh and also became the director of intelligence for west germany at the end of
world war ii you know at the behest of our oss we got him put in there you know and shackley
worked directly with him you know yeah and and uh and uh also um adolf skorzeny another former nazi
yeah adolf skorzeny who ran the rat line uh-huh you know of smuggling them all out of there and
they were knights of malta passports
that were used did you i mean you're a jesuit did you ever use your jesuit connections to figure out
more about the magenta crash which was supposedly recovered you know according to david grush
it was recovered in lombardi in 1933 and uh i believe the cardinal of milan was also a knight
of malta at the time and the ufo supposedly made itself to the vatican where it was held for
a while and then i think pope pius the sixth maybe
uh then you know transferred it over to the u.s it's the 11th the pope pius the 11th okay
transferred it over to the u.s um so do you know anything about that no no i didn't actually
it's interesting do you believe that's a real case or it's interesting i didn't know about it
okay i didn't know about it until comparatively recently okay uh so that one never came across
the radar yeah so i had i had been pretty well locked down on you gotta hit up your vatican
those that are still alive anyway uh you know i mean they're all dead i couldn't believe it i mean
virtually everybody that was there in the staff when i was there have all passed away it's totally
bizarre uh but uh but the bottom line is i didn't know about that one at all and no one has ever
said anything to me about it you know and when i when i talked to johan it's who was the head of
the vatican archives you know he's just always just smiled i mean and has to give you a smile
a smile of quiet
knowing oh yeah oh yeah no he knows because because i sent the letters to them from jesuit
headquarters to ask for access for president carter so he doesn't give you a befuddled
laughing smile or something okay no it'd be perfectly easy for them to say look there's
nothing to this you're crazy okay no but no he knows he knows that i know interesting stuff is
there interesting and he just isn't gonna let me have it so you you were the um lawyer for john
mack yeah who's the head of the harvard psychiatry department and
hell did friend of bud hopkins towards the end of his career he started to take very seriously
these uh uh experiencers people would experience abductions or alien contact and often it would
come out in hypnotic regression or through holotropic breath work which was one of his
favorite kind of modalities that was and um you have his final manuscript they do and he writes
about i heard at the end of his life he started to get into reptilians and was like interested in and
Reptilians specifically? I don't know. Is there anything interesting in that final manuscript that sort of shows his overall worldview at the end of this, you know, decade plus long inquiry into the UFO alien question?
Yeah, he really views the entire UFO ET issue as a window opening onto the functioning of worldviews, you know, in our human family to really explain. I had something to do with that, because that's what I was talking to him about. He and I, just before he got killed, we were planning on trying to set up a thing.
When you say he got killed, was that, do you think it was intentionally or accidentally?
No, it was accidentally.
Okay, car hit him.
No, yeah, yeah, no.
In Europe?
Yeah, I was on that within hours after it happened.
So sad.
I dug it out and knew who the guy was, the guy still in prison that ran him down. He was just drunk. And, you know, yeah. And so that John and I were talking about the fact that this was a, actually the name of his manuscript is When Worldviews Collide.
Hmm.
And, you know, I'll do Velikovsky, I'll do that, you know, from When Worlds Collide.
So that's what he did.
To play on that.
It's When Worlds Collide.
Yeah.
What was the Velikovsky, what was the When Worlds Collide, what was that about?
When Worlds Collide is an old classic piece that Velikovsky wrote. It's the theory that the asteroid belt is another planet that was here in our solar system.
Hmm.
And it collided with the...
The moon or something.
Hmm.
I just remember it.
And it believes that it blew up.
Oh, yeah, that's right. It's like the Kuiber belt or something.
Yeah.
The whole asteroid belt is really that planet.
Ah.
All blown up into shrapnel, basically, all through the asteroid belt.
And so Mack was saying When Worldviews Collide, like the kind of Western materialist reductionist worldview and the...
And this worldview.
The animistic worldview or something.
Yeah.
One that encapsulated life beyond humans.
So it's like to the point where you shatter the Western mental structures, the Western mind, so to speak, which is not permeating the whole earth, and it's materialist, dualistic philosophy.
The way you do it is you take something that's supposed to be in the spirit world.
Because even in the West, we can make allowance for the spirit world, and we can study it through mythology, through religion, through imagination, through poetry.
But the one...
is when something that should be in the spirit world transgresses and shows up
in the physical world that traffic is the cardinal sin for the Western mind so
it has great power to shatter the belief structure of the Western mind when that
occurs and that's precisely what's occurring and so he started really
starting to perceive things because I was some assistance in that because I I
had you know done the master's degree work and then started the PhD work at
Harvard on that very issue trying to under trying to understand things when
you get a really complex issue what you want to do is figure out what the kind
of operational pieces of it are so you can get them spread out in front of just
like a plane wreck you know you want to kind of reassemble the pieces that you
can recover and take a look at it and what this does is it tends to shake down
into this octave
of human worldviews you know that the that only one aspect of which is their
political manifestation you know that that runs from from right to left you
know from the authoritarian to the reactionary to the conservative to the
moderate to the liberal to the progressive to the utopianist you know
that there's there's a there are integrated worldviews they're internally
self referentially consistent you know and that they're all predicated upon
the answers that you provide to these four pillar questions about the origins
of the universe the kind of end product the teleological outcome of the universe
is projected you know what the analogical relationship between
consciousness and the material manifestation of reality is the big one
yeah and the epistemological question is you know that what means do we have at
our disposal as human beings by means of which you can possibly answer questions
like that you know it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's and it's and it's essentially
like in some human musical class you are so the how you frame your
language you are here to connect me to a very powerful rainbow like might я смущен
if the earth was a Bart vitamin to give you an answer to all those issues you
you have a worldview.
It's a systematic worldview.
And if you can discern what the common principle is
that makes all of them similar to each other,
the answers are consistent with each other,
you apply that principle to any question that you confront
in making your judgments.
And then you have a philosophy.
That's what a philosophy is,
is a consistent application of a single principle
that is generic to all four of these fundamental questions,
if you can do that, and that that's what a philosophy is.
And then you have a sub-component of that,
your political philosophy,
and then you have a mode of spiritual expression,
which is generic to that.
That's where you get these major world religions
that are generic to a particular worldview.
And so I was starting to explain all that to him
that I discovered when I actually went back
to talk to John Rawls,
who's the head of the Department of Philosophy,
at Harvard.
You know, when I was running into these conflicts
that I was having with the different lawyers
in the firms where I was,
you know, they all seemed to be functioning
on some different wavelength.
So what did Mack think, you know,
when, what would happen when worldviews collided,
and when-
He believes that it's absolutely clear
that there's, that the initial response that we have
as human beings, as homo sapien,
to an encounter with an extraterrestrial,
an extraterrestrial being,
is that it kind of shatters the kind of walls
of the room, the mansion of our worldview, you know,
that all of a sudden the things are so completely different
than anything you'd ever assumed before
that your world can fall apart, as it were.
And so people, and people have this kind of cellular response
when you find yourself actually confronted
with an extraterrestrial being,
that your whole cellular system reacts, you know,
in a kind of a fight or flight way
that your subconscious doesn't have any control over.
It's just, you just freak out, you know?
And so we started deciding that what we wanted to do
is help train people that had consistent repeated encounters,
you know, because we found that to be a fairly common theme.
That if you've been abducted once,
you've been usually abducted more than once, right?
And so that if it's going to happen again,
to try to train a person through holotropic breathing
to kind of just calm themselves down,
and to get centered, to try to get mastery
over that kind of cellular response that your body has.
Because all of us that are alive right now
are the end of the chain of survivors.
I mean, that's what's distinguished us, you know,
that our lineage have all survived.
Yeah.
And gotten us through to where we are now.
That's fascinating though.
He's talking about almost like a manual
for being physiologically ready for contact.
That's right, absolutely right.
To try to overcome the cellular imprint that we have in us
to react like that.
The allergic reaction.
Yeah.
And it is like if you're, you know,
like the three body problem,
if you're in the dark forest
and you are afraid of making contact,
it's actually adaptive to sort of hide yourself.
You would want to know that the other side
is sort of receptive and stable and going to be okay.
Yes, yes.
You know, when you appear.
Oh, that's right.
Because if you, you know, cause this.
Oh, they get in trouble.
I mean, you know, Karen, one of the,
they used to throw things at them.
I mean, she would throw lamps at them.
She was one of Mac's patients.
She was one of the ladies.
That's a little crazy, yeah.
Yeah, and she was one of the first people
who really got the holotropic breathing training.
So are you gonna release this book
or what are you planning on doing with this?
I haven't ever, he just gave it to me
because he was getting set to go to England
to do this lecture.
Yeah.
On T.E. Lawrence and wanted me to go through it
because it covers a lot of the encounter we had
with the faculty committee.
Yeah.
It's kind of his account of what happened.
He was such an interesting guy.
Well, he won a Pulitzer Prize for his book
called The Prince of Disorder, which is about.
The Prince of Our Disorder.
Prince of Our Disorder, about T.E. Lawrence.
He was Lawrence of Arabia.
Yeah, it was a psycho biography.
Right.
Of Lawrence.
Who I believe was, he was gay
and he had been sort of sexually assaulted multiple times
and he had this sort of crazy,
and then he led this uprising, you know, and.
He's a pretty fascinating character.
Fascinating character.
And Mack himself was such a fascinating character.
I feel like his search for the UFO and alien question
was kind of motivated by some autobiographical stuff
with his mother, who I think,
did she die during childbirth or when he was very young?
No, no, no, no.
In fact, his mother played this really kind of
major role in that.
Okay.
Because he, when he first got dragged up,
well, when he first started encountering
these high level military officials
that were ordered to get a psychiatric exam
to try to deter them from really pressing
any farther on this,
it was the first thing that would happen
that they'd be ordered to get a psychiatric exam.
Because they'd seen an alien or something?
Yeah, because they wanted to file a report.
They wanted to file a report about, you know,
a UFO encounter and they were always told that, you know,
like, you don't want to do this.
This is not good for your career.
Did John Mack, was he kind of abreast
of any of the UFO stuff from his Navy experience
or no, it came later?
No, nothing, no.
He was a complete agnostic, you know, to start with.
And then he got sent these, like Arne Arnolson,
who was the actual commander of the Montana base,
you know, the Minuteman base.
Malmstrom.
That he was the actual commander
that filed the report with NORAD about it all.
And then they said, are you trying to file a UFO report?
Is that what you're doing?
And he said, yes.
He said it was the most important moment of his life.
He just said, yes, I am.
He says, I am not letting this one go.
You know, because they shut off all of us.
They shut off 10 silos.
Independent, independently wired nukes.
Yeah. Minutemen.
Yeah. Yeah.
And so he was adamant that he was going to get that filed.
And so, you know, he and a number of other
high-ranking military people had been sent to John Mack
at Harvard as the head of the Department of Clinical
Psychiatry to do the psychiatric workup on these guys.
And after a half a dozen of these folks,
he started saying, wait a second,
this doesn't make any sense at all.
He said, you know, these are high-ranking military people.
There's lawyers and doctors.
There's all kinds of people that are coming
to report these things.
Doesn't make any sense.
And so he started this actually kind of like
a little investigation.
And he would train them to do the holotropic breathing
and get them calmed down and centered, right?
And then he was asking them questions.
Okay, now you're inside the craft.
Look around and tell me what you're seeing.
And he was getting them to give little reports
on these totally esoteric things, you know,
that nobody would really make up, you know.
And then he would see if other people saw similar stuff,
you know, and he was verifying.
So he started, got to the point where he said,
wait a second, there's something really happening here.
There's something wrong with these people.
And so he called his mother.
So she didn't die in childbirth.
So he called her and she said, oh, you ought to check
with Bud, the Hopkins kid, you know,
that he's into this stuff, you know,
even though he's a sculptor and artist
and all that kind of stuff.
But, you know, that our families are close
and he knows a lot about this.
And so that's how it happened is that he ended up
talking to Bud Hopkins.
And Hopkins said, oh, look, let me show you, you know.
And he started giving him a lot more people.
And so by the time he contacted me, you know,
he'd interviewed like a hundred people, you know,
who'd had these experiences.
And so he ended up calling me.
And when he got confronted by this faculty committee
and they called me and asked me
if I would legally represent him.
And so I went there and confronted the, you know,
faculty committee, you know, and, but very fortunately went with John to meet with Lawrence
Rockefeller and Lawrence Rockefeller, you know, told us all about, you know, his best friend
seeing a UFO. That's why he was convinced it was true. Yeah. Lawrence Rockefeller was a patron for
a lot of early UFO research. He funded John Mack. He funded Stephen Greer. Uh, I think Whitley
Stryber has told me a story about meeting with Lawrence Rockefeller in Wyoming and the Tetons
at his ranch or whatever. Why do you think Lawrence Rockefeller was so interested in the
subject? So you mentioned that his friend had an experience. That's interesting. Whitley is the
Prince of Lichtenstein, Hans Adams, whoever it was. That's all. He's apparently extremely
interested in UFOs. It was his best friend. I think he thinks that Jesus is going to come down
on a saucer or something. It's like some eschatological worldview. I don't, I didn't
know. He just told us. He gathered the guy named John Brandenburg, who I interviewed,
said, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't
know. He said that, uh, Prince Hans Adams, um, had, uh, gathered all of the, uh, Roswell, uh,
witnesses, I think in the seventies or something or the eighties. I don't know what, you know,
and, uh, that he wanted to speak to all of them and kind of, you know, uh, understand what had
happened. Oh yeah. So he was very interested in this. And Lawrence told us that, you know,
cause he said, that's why he was so convinced that it was true that his friend who was the
Prince of Lichtenstein had seen one. Yeah. And, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and,
uh, in that, uh, had actually walked right up onto one, you know, that was in, that was up in
the mountains, very similar to a, to a, uh, an experience of one of the guys that I knew,
you know, the, the son of, uh, uh, Bill Todman, you know, Mark Goodson and Bill Todman,
Mark Goodson and Bill Todman were the guys that used to produce I Love Lucy and the $64,000
question and that tune, all those kind of quizzy shows kind of things back in the fifties.
It made millions, you know, and, uh, and, uh, I was out, I was out at the, we were, we were,
uh, Mace Neufeld and Bob Ramey had contacted me, the guy that do all the Tom Clancy movies.
They wanted to do the Iran Contra movie. And so they, they contacted me to talk with them down
in, down in LA. And I was down in the office with, uh, Bob Ramey, the, who was the president
of the Academy of Arts and Science. He was the head of the Oscars thing, you know?
And, uh, so we were talking with him and his, his, uh, executive, uh, his exec, uh, uh, his name,
uh, uh, I forgot his name, but anyway, that, that he contacts me, uh, and, and said, uh, he said,
look, there's a, uh, friend of mine that wants to talk to you. The, you know, would you, he told
me not to say who he is, but would you trust me to, to, uh, take you there to him? So I said,
okay, we'll do that.
So, so we went out and, uh, what was the guy's name? Anyway, we go out, get into his big red
Cadillac convertible and we drive off into, uh, Warner Brothers and we go over to the Warner
Brothers lot and we go in and it turns out that it's, uh, Bill Todman's son of Mark Goodson and
Bill Todman. So here's his son who's now, uh, uh, a, an exec in Warner Brothers, you know? And,
uh, and he wanted to tell me about an experience that he had had and that he had, uh,
he was, uh, in college and he was, uh, on summer break and he was in the Tetons outside of Boulder.
Uh, and he was climbing in the Tetons and he came up into this meadow and there was a UFO just
sitting right, hovering right there in the meadow. And he walked all the way over to it and, and put
his hand on it. I said, and it was like alive. He said, this is alive, this thing, you know? And
then the, the whole thing started kind of shuddering and, and raised up. So he backed away from it.
And it just went, went and shot away. And he, he wouldn't, he didn't dare tell anybody cause he
thought that they would ruin his whole reputation and stuff in the industry. Um, but, uh, it turns
out that he said that his father, Mark Goodson, uh, senior or Bill Todman senior, uh, was, uh,
best friends with, uh, uh, he's this big famous, uh, author that, uh, writes these romance novels
anyway, that, uh, uh, you know, uh, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and,
and he wrote he wrote a book about it uh partly because bill todman jr told him that he'd had
this experience he wrote a thing called the doomsday the doomsday uh doomsday plan or
something who's the author um sydney sheldon his name was and he wrote like 50 of these you know
books you know made millions of dollars he too wouldn't dare ever be public about it so he wrote
this book called the doomsday project you know a a hypothetical of a of a a a saucer that had
crashed uh in a tour bus over in italy or somewhere it happened to be driving by when
they were doing a recovery of it and so this young lieutenant colonel in the naval intelligence was
assigned to find out where all the people were that were on the bus that saw this because they
just wanted to explain to them that this was just an experimental uh thing you know so that they
wouldn't be distressed well it turns out they all started getting killed all these witnesses and uh
and and so uh sydney sheldon wrote this book it's complete fiction about it and that's the only time
he ever said anything about it and then went right back to his normal life wow and so uh so bill
todman jr wanted me to know about this just to tell me and so i've been constantly trying to get him
said why don't you go public yeah you got more money than the pope you know now from your
inheritance why don't you he won't do it he still hasn't agreed to do anything well you've done it
for him now yeah but yeah because he was perfectly honest about it i didn't have any doubt that it was
sure sure yeah well he's a real nice guy yeah but it still hasn't done anything danny it's exciting
times right now do you have a prediction for the next uh three months of disclosure and the ufo
some of it's easy so you know the the the the senate bill is going to get repassed you know
all 64 pages exactly the same the senator round it's it's rounds is going to sound yeah from south
dakota he's going to sponsor it uh and i'm i'm i'm sure that uh that uh that uh uh the the uh
schumer will co-sponsor it uh we don't we don't we don't have uh uh marco around anymore ribia
rubio to sponsor but but you know we're hoping to try to get state department in on this okay
because there's this whole state department dimension that is totally inappropriate for
the state department not to have been brought in on this i mean you're dealing with an entire foreign
power here uh in the they're being x'd out so i mean now that rubio's over there you know he ought
to yeah he's very interested in on record on sure you know this whole topic and sure he is um yeah
one of his aides was probably as deep as it gets on the topic as much as it gets on the topic as
much as it gets on the topic as much as it gets on the topic as much as it gets on the topic as
well and was sort of you know uh i think encountered a bunch of obstacles as a result of
his involvement yeah yeah so so the bottom line is they're gonna they're gonna the senate is gonna
pass the the 64-page bill again uh probably around the middle of july between july 15th 20th or so
that they'll they'll pass it and they'll send it on over the house you know we're we're focusing on
crenshaw crenshaw you know dan crenshaw is now the new head of the intelligence committee
in the house and that's where we ran into trouble before it was primarily mike turner
who was the the uh congressman from ohio right part right patterson uh district you know it was
it was stopping the the full bill from being passed crenshaw pro ufo and transparency we don't
know yet we're trying to get but he's he's uh he's certainly not uh anywhere near as bad as
turner was you know turner had his own personal agenda because of his
constituency there you know with the with the base but but crenshaw's a a guy that's you know
been critical of things he doesn't agree with he's he's kind of a bit of a maverick uh and he's got a
lot of integrity you know tough guy you know it's a is a seal team dude you know but uh but i touch
yeah yeah yeah but he's not he's not just kind of a knee-jerk reactionary yeah you know so he's
there's a real promise there and so we're going to be meeting with him and his staff
try to get him to see if he can give a a leadership in the intelligence committee
to green light the full bill you know or at least a lot more of it we've gotten 23 pages
of the 64 passed with unfortunate some amendments even with that part yep but
but the bottom line what we're after is the appointment of the board that we we want to
get that portion of the 64-page bill done at least this time around is to get the get the
the the panel uh appointed you know now one of the challenges is that well our new paradigm
institute is one of the groups that's authorized to to make recommendations uh under the statute
but the president is the one ultimately decides who's going to who he's going to appoint the
congress can mandate that he do it they can pass the statute and say the president is to appoint
this board you know but then he could you know he could appoint
you know to be on it or whatever he wants to do and so we're we're going to try to appoint
we're trying to recommend a group that is that is sort of almost beyond uh beyond criticism you know
the kind of people the kind of people you'd really want to have there and then hope that that will
cause trump to say okay good that's a good group let's have them do it uh so we're hoping this year
we're hoping that that will cause trump to say okay good that's a good group let's have them do it
this side of the next election this side of the election in 2026 to get an additional chunk of the
64-page bill passed specifically the part having to do with the with the board okay and we're going
to have you know it's going to be a dynamic going on with this board they're going to be a lot of
people inside the national security infrastructure they're going to want to have people in there
that are going to continue to keep it as sphinctered as possible uh you know
and then there's gonna be lots of people putting pressure on us to try to have it be you know here
let's have it all you know like like uh burchette you know let's just order the president to reveal
everything right now just dump it on everybody you know that's so there's there are extremes
all around us here but what we're trying to do is kind of navigate our way through to to really the
the dynamic that's going to take place hopefully uh between now and november of 2026 you know uh
now we've got the we've got the uh end of september coming here in 2025 when that's
the extension that the the uh national archives has given to the military services and the
intelligence community to to gather together all the information they've got okay and that
that that's in this that's a standing order that they've got you know it's still got that
wiggle language in there saying in there to turn it over to the national archives as soon as possible
you know the the senate bill said immediately and they gave them the drop dead date of october 20th
you know and now they've managed to get the house to water it down say as soon as possible
so my sense is their lawyers are going to push back against us but so i'm not i'm not i i don't
give it more than a 51 chance you know that we're going to get any kind of meaningful release of
that information yeah uh and at the end of september here well danny you're doing the lord's
work and uh godspeed i'm excited to see what what happens uh in the next few months and years and
uh you're you're a really important champion for this whole topic and i hope that
uh you know as as much as i love you know my own podcast i hope that you go on like tucker carlson
or joe rogan or something and uh the jf the jfk thing is so important and i know both are so
interested in it and i i you know i i dabble and like i you know i've i've learned you know from
oliver stone and you know red uh you know mark lane and and jim mars and all these guys and like
i think you're the best living um retailer of the entire story in a way that is a coherent
narrative with all the players but you also talk about motives and yeah so i think uh it
would be great if you um if that was amplified as much as possible no i'd be happy to do it you know
the you know no no interview is any better than the interviewer
that's true that's true well i think they're both great but i mean they more importantly than that
if they have much bigger platforms than me i mean i have a big platform but there's their next level
so well biggest in the world yeah they both seem to be sincerely interested you know and so that's
the key you know and they're they're not particularly biased or prejudiced in any way
about it no and and be and because they they straddle different kind of world views you know
and reach out to people that are at
here in some different world views it's a valuable forum yeah those both of those guys yeah well
danny it's an honor man appreciate you taking the time this is always awesome yeah always learned so
much